لوسيد قاعدة تبيع بخسارة
قاعدة تبيع وتخسر أظن 250 أو 300 ألف دولار
على كل سيارة تبيعها بقيمة 100 ألف دولار أو شيء، مبلغ ضخم
قاعد تخسر مبالغ ضخمة
الحين المشكلة ما نعرف في السعودية، بتقدر تربح وللا لا؟
أهلًا هذا فنجان من ثمانية، وأنا عبد الرحمن أبو مالح
دول الخليج العربية بينها تجارة بينية تصل إلى 12%
وبينها تقارب شديد في شكل الاقتصاد، وماهيَّة الإصلاحات
وحتى شكل المستقبل لدولنا
اليوم التجارة البينية أسهل
العمل لمواطني دول الخليج يُعاملون معاملة المواطن إلى حد كبير
التنقل بالهوية الوطنية والتعرفة الجمركية
وغيرها من الاتفاقيات بين الدول هذه
السؤال، هل ممكن تزداد هذه التنسيقات والاتفاقيات
لتصل إلى اتحاد اقتصادي أو اتحاد يشبه الاتحاد الأوربي؟
هل فكرة العملة الموحدة فكرة منطقية؟ أو فكرة ممكنة؟
اليوم نعيش تحولات تأخذ دول الخليج العربية إلى مرحلة عالم ما بعد النفط
إلا أن التباين بين كم وشكل الإصلاحات واضح
السعودية مثلًا ضريبة القيمة المضافة فيها 15% والكويت 0%
دول الخليج لا تنوي فرض ضريبة الدخل
بينما عُمان تنوي تطبيقها العام المقبل
السعودية والإمارات وقطر تستثمر في الأندية الرياضية وأسواق الطيران
لتسيطر على السوق العالمي
والسعودية والإمارات تستثمر في صناعة السيارات
فأنشأت السعودية شركة «سير» واستثمرت كذلك في شركة «لوسيد»
السياحة تشكل جزء ضخمًا من اقتصاد مدينة دبي
وهي كذلك مُستهدف واضح وقوي لدى السعودية
لتصبح السياحة عامودًا من أعمدة التحول الاقتصادي
ما بين التشابه في بداية كلامي، وما بين الاختلاف في الجزء الثاني
حديث ونقاش ممتع ومُثري مع ضيفي حمد الماجدي
قبل أن نبدأ، إذا كنت مهتم بمواضيع ريادة الأعمال، وخفايا عالم الاستثمار
فودّي أنصحك في بودكاست دسم في هذا المجال، بودكاست «السوق»
كل يوم اثنين يجتمع معاذ خليفاوي، وعبدالله سعيدان
بصفتهم خبراء، ومستثمرين
يحللون لك تحركات الشركات، ويناقشون مستجدًّات الأسواق العالمية
اشترك من الرابط الموجود في الوصف عشان يصلك جديد للحلقات
وبإمكانك برضو مشاهدة النسخة المرئية منها على اليوتيوب
على قناة «إذاعة ثمانية» في نفس الموعد
شكرًا لراعي الحلقة شركة «صفا» ومنصة «سلة»
أما الآن لنبدأ
أيش الأخبار؟
تمام والله
أيش العلوم؟
يا أخي جوكم شيء خطير
والله
أنا جايك مو جاهز، شوف كل كناديري...
جاي وكناديري خفيفة على أساس جو الإمارات
احنا ترى الشتاء ما جاءنا للحين، بعدنا عايشين في حر
نتمشى في الليل، ونعرق، يعني ما في فايدة
ننتظر الشتاء يدخل علينا
حتى الشتاء هنا تأخر يعني مو...
عندكم أنتم؟
إي
يا أخي في الليل براد، أمس رحنا «وينتر قاردن» يا أخي الجو برد
حلو البرد
جدَّا وشوف أنت، ما شاء الله، بعد مِشتِّي خلاص دخلت
أظن تطلع قيمتهم يمكن أكثر من أن تدفى فيهم
صحيح أبغى أوريك مفاجأة
بس لحظة جابوه هنا، ولا أنت بتأخده من الإمارات وتجيبها؟
إيوه
أيش اللي خلَّاك، وكيف غيرت رأيك؟
أيش كنت أقول لك يوم التقينا؟
أنها «كوريلا»
أي «كوريلا» ومستحيل، ولا تكلمني، واللي يأخذها ما يفهم
ساعات الواحد يغير رأيه
بس أيش اللي خلَّاك تغير رأيك؟ أنت سايقها؟
أنا جربت الأربع نواع كلها
جربت «ثري» و«واي» و«إكس» و«إس»
بس أنا جربتهم قديمًا، يعني خصوصًا «إس» جربتها زمان ألفين و..
سنة 2017-2018
سنة 2017 وما عجبتني أبدًا
عشان كذا كنت زعلان لما أقول لك «كوريلا» كانت فعلًا «كوريلا»
ما له علاقة بالفخامة، ولا لها علاقة بالصناعة، ولا لها علاقة بأي شيء
تلقاه عادي أن في أشياء ما هي مركبة تحس إنها تركيب
تضغط عليها تسمع صوت خشب يتحرك بمكانه
طيب مرة مزعج، يعني ما تسويها «تويوتا» وهي «تويوتا»
مع أن «تويوتا» المفترض أنها...
جربت «البلاد»؟ أنت طلبت «البلاد» ولا؟
أنا جربت «البلاد» إي أعجبتني وطلبت «البلاد»
بس أيش بتسوي يا أخي الموضوع مزعج أنك تجيبها السعودية
وأي وقت بتتصلح تشحنها لدبي
هي ما تحتاج بس، لا سمح الله، سويت حادث أو شيء روح وحولها
ما أدري والله إيش أسوي، لعله يفتح وكيل في السعودية
بس في عندكم لا، شوف «إيلون ماسك» شرطه ما يفتح مع وكيل
ليه اللي في الإمارات مو وكيل؟
مو وكيل
متأكد؟
مليون في المئة
شركتين في الإمارات فاتحين بدون وكيل، أبل وتسلا
«محمد القرقاوي» زار إيلون ماسك في سنة 2015
قال: تعال افتح عنَّا في الإمارات
قال له: كيف؟
قال: لازم وكيل
قال له: سامحني
ما أجي
ما جاء
في 2017 رجع مرة ثانية عنده
في 2017 أو 2016 ما أتذكر، أعتقد 2017
رجع وقال له: افتح بدون وكيل
قال له: أكيد؟
قال: أكيد
قال: حسنًا تَم. فتح له وجابه
عجيب اختياراتهم بعد، يعني الإمارات والأردن
الأردن ما فهمتها الصراحة
يعني لا هي قوة شرائية، ولا بنية تحتية أنك جاهز
فأيش اللي خلَّاهم صراحة؟ ما أدري
وعلى فكرة الإمارات، عملية الصناعة يوم صارت صعبة عليها
بالنسبة للنموذج «ثري» والنموذج «واي»
وقفوها على بعض الدول
الأردن كانت منهم، سنة كاملة ما استلموا ولا شيء، سنة ونص يمكن
حتى كنت أدخل بالعادة أحب أشوف أسعار في مختلف الدول
أسجل عندي «ورقة أكسل» أطالع وأشوف المتغيرات بين دولة لدولة
طبعًا تأخذ بعين الاعتبار في ضريبة
بس أبغى أعرف من ناحية فنية
وين ممكن تشتريها من أرخص مكان، ووين أغلى مكان
والمتغيرات أرخص مكان، كان أعتقد الصين
وأغلى مكان كان...
النرويج
أعتقد لا مش النرويج ما أدري كانت هونق كونق أو دولة ثانية
كان تقريبًا ما أقول لك الضعف
بس حوالي 70% زيادة نفس السيارة ونفس المواصفات
طبعًا حط في بالك أن بعض الدول، يمكن ماني دقيق في الموضوع هذا
لكن بعض الدول اللي عندها «نقل عام» ممتاز
تضرب عليك ضريبة ضخمة على السيارات
عشان تتعمد أنك ما تجيبها، حتى لو كهربائية، أهم شيء لا تجيبها
بس بعضهم عشان يحفزون الكهرباء يسوون خصم للضرائب وغيرها
بالضبط، مثل أمريكا إلى الحين عندك 7500 ائتمان بالدولار
على بعض السيارات اللي تطابق بعض الشروط
الكهربائية؟
إي
لا، بس أنا قلت هنا صح أنه فيها مشكلة أني ما أقدر أسافر أي مكان
أنا أحب أسافر بالسيارة، بس هذا موضوع بحلَّه
بس هذا المفروض...
بس أشحنها في البيت وخلاص
واحنا بدأنا نحل هذه المشكلة مع «أدنوك» وصار في كذا شركات ثانية
تعاقدت مع الحكومة
عشان نسوي شاحنات مختلفة على مختلف الأماكن بالإمارات
بالذات محطات البترول، قال كل محطة بترول بنحط لها شاحنتين
طبعًا المعدل أغلى بكثير من...
بس على الأقل يوفر لك حل عشان ما تتورط
بس أحيانًا تسلا تمشيك تقريبًا الإمارات كلها خلاص
حطوا لك توصل إلى حدود السعودية تسلا توديك
ومن ناحية الفائقة الشحن بالذات
لأن هذا اللي يفرق
حتى الحين في أمريكا صارت تسلا تأجر محطاتها للسيارات الثانية
صح، تأجر وممكن أنك تروح تدفع، وتحصل وصول عليها
بس إذا سيارتك متوافقة مع شواحن...
بس الحين كل أحد جالس يعتمد نظامهم
هم فعليًّا بدأوا نظام الصناعة
اللي اسمه «أن.ايه.أس» أعتقد «معيار أمريكا الشمالية»
اللي هو الصغير جدًّا وسريع جدًّا
احنا عندنا بعدنا على النظام القديم
يعني اللي أنا شحن سيارتي يوميًّا تأخذ لها تقريبًا أربعة ساعات ونصف
كويس
بس البطارية مُتعبة
عندي «النموذج واي» البطارية متعبة ما تمشيك إلا فعليًّا...
شوف أنت ما تشحنها 100% لازم تشحن إلى 90% فتخسر 10% فوق
لازم ما تنزلها تحت الـ 20% عشان البطارية ما تتضرر على المدى الطويل
فأنت فعليًّا أنت تدفع للـ70% الموجودة في النص
فأي مبلغ وأي رقم تشوفه اضربه بـ70%
ولو تبغى تكون أكثر دقة، اضربه ب65% وهذا اللي راح تستخدمه فعليًّا
فأنا فعليًّا اللي أستخدمه 380 يمكن 400 بالكثير
الله يعين يا رب
بس الحين دائمًا أكون أسولف مع أحد على السيارة
فيقول لي نفس الشيء كيف بتصلحها؟ وما أدري شلون
بس أحس التصليح بسيط، بس التأمين هو المشكلة
بس برضو وين بتشحنها؟ فأنا أقول الحين بشحنها في البيت
بس فعليًّا المفترض أن يكون فيه بنية تحتية للسيارات الكهربائية
أعتقد أن قبل كم شهر أعلن صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
أنه سيأسس شركة بنية تحتية للسيارات الكهربائية، أتوقع شيء زي كذا
وأعتقد أنه فيه مستهدف، أنا ما أدري كيف بيوصلون له
يا إما من الرياض، يا إما من السعودية
أن 25% من السيارات تكون كهربائية في سنة 2030
خصوصا أننا الآن احنا نتكلم عن أن أبغى أجيب سيارة
وجالس أقول وين أشحنها؟
فما أعرف، والحين السعودية برضو مستثمرة في «لوسيد»
وأسست شركة «سير» والإمارات برضو
«ربدان»
«ربدان» وبدأت تبيع ولا؟
إلى الحين نماذج مبدئية
اللي بدأوا يشتغلونهم هم مجموعات صغيرة، لكن ما تشوفها في الشوارع
للحين ما أشوفها في الشوارع صراحة
وسمعت أنه عندهم معرض بس ما رحت شفته الصراحة
كيف تشوف فكرة السيارات الكهربائية في الدول النفطية؟
هل هو صح، وللا غلط؟ يعني أيش السالفة؟
شوف هو أكيد صح لأنه ما تقدر أنك تحارب التكنولوجيا
هي السيارات جاية جاية
ويبين الشيء هذا من ردود أفعال الناس
احنا عندنا كلما، أتذكر سنة 2021 لما كانت أسعار النفط ترتفع
كلما ترتفع، أنا كنت أتاجر بسيارات تسلا ترى، زين
كلما ترتفع تشوف الناس مستعدة تدفع زيادة أعلى على السيارة
يعني تطلبها
المعاملة كانت بسيطة تطلبها، وتوصل البلد
تأخذها، وترد تبيعها على طول
يوصلوا لك إياها إلى باب البيت
أنت بس اللي عليك تدفع نقدًا، ما تتورط مع البنك
لأن عملية أنك تخلص القرض، شوي مزعجة
فتشوف ناس مستعدة تدفع 30-40 ألف زيادة فوق سعر الوكالة
لأن الطلب عليها...، لأن سعر البترول غالي، والناس تبغى ترتاح منه تمامًا
والتقييمات من الناس اللي كانوا يسوقون السيارة
كان يقول لك يا أخي تريحني من عملية البترول، وتريحني من عملية الصيانة
وتعيش عمر أطول
أكثر تسلا ماشية أظن في العالم
مسجلينها كانت بين لوس آنقلوس ولاس فيقاس شغالة تاكسي
كانت ماشية مجموع أظن 2.2 أو 2.3 مليون كيلومتر
البطارية تبدَّلها ثلاث مرات تحت الضمان
هذيك الأيام الضمان مفتوح على ثماني سنوات
الحين الحد على 192 ألف كيلومتر، لكن أقول لك: السيارة تمشي
أنا أعرف ناس عندهم تسلا في البلد، نصف مليون ماشية
نموذج «إكس» تقريبًا فيها مشاكل بعد، الجديدة الممتازة
فعودة إلى سؤالك، هل هي صح ولا لا؟
وكيف ممكن ترتبها في السعودية
الحين السعودية ماخذة رهان قوي على «لوسيد»
فالسؤال هو الحين «لوسيد» آخر فترة ما قاعدة تؤدي بالطريقة المطلوبة
عندك سنة عن سنة الإنتاج مثلما هو راكد
عدد الطلبات قاعد يزيد، والمشكلة السعر واجد غالي
فالسؤال هو، السعودية لمتى ناوية تستمر مع «لوسيد»؟
أقول لك: من ناحية... لمتى تستمر؟ أيش أقصد
أقصد هل بتتم تخليها شركة خاصة عفوًا شركة...
عامة
عامة أو تحولها شركة خاصة
وجهة نظري أن وجودها كشركة عامة ما راح يستمر، بالذات بالطريقة هذه
لأن صار لهم تقريبًا سنتين أو سنتين ونص والموضوع مثلما هو
قاعد تنزل نماذج جديدة
لكن هي مش ملحقة تخلص الطلبات القديمة أساسًا
وغير هذا أسعارها واجد غالية
لو ترجع لتصريحات إيلون ماسك القديمة عن أيام النموذج «ثري»
قالوا له ليش أنت حاكر على الناس الخيارات واجد قليلة
الألوان جدَّا محدودة؟
قال أنت تبي سيارة ممكن تبيعها على نطاق واسع وتنتجها بالشكل...؟
قال هذه الأمور لازم هذه المقايضات اللي أنت لازم تأخذها
قال مش بإيدنا
في النهاية الطلب علينا ضخم
هل أنا أروح أعطي الناس لون غير أو خيار غير أو نوع جلد غير
ولا أروح أعطيهم سيارة جاهزة يستلمونها وخلاص؟
خاصة عندي ملايين واقفين
«لوسيد» في وقت من الأوقات كان عندها
ما أذكر كم، بس أعتقد 100 ألف حجز، وأغلبهم من السعودية طبعًا
كثير منهم ألغوا، لأنهم خلاص تعبوا، كم بينتظرون؟
وبعضهم لما استلموا...
وبعضهم حطوا وديعة بدون يعرفون السعر النهائي
لما وصل السعر النهائي صُدموا 800 - 900 - 700 ألف
وطبعًا شروط الوديعة كانت أنها قابلة للاسترداد، فكثير منهم استردوها
أنت عندك شركة لا قادرة تبيع على نطاق واسع
ولا قادرة تبيع بسعر مقبول للناس
وهذا بدون...، تسلا أول شيء سوَّت سيارة، وبعدين بدأت بالبنية التحتية
اللي هو الشاحن الفائق عشان الناس تقدر تستعملها بشكل مريح
فأنت لا عندك السيارة ولا قادر تبيع
أيش اللي بيخليك تنتج البنية التحتية؟
البنية التحتية
البنية التحتية اللي أنت تحتاجها، ما بتقدر
فإذا السعودية تبغى فعلًا أنها تكون عندها بنية تحتية ممتازة
وجهة نظري هي إذا ما قدرت تصلح شركة لوسد
من ناحية الإدارة والإنتاج وغيرها
تروح وتستقطب تسلا تجيبها للبلاد، وتقول تعالوا اشتغلوا عندنا
طبعًا نبغى نفس نظام في الإمارات أتوقع
لأن تسلا ما أتوقع توافق على شيء ثاني
العلم أنه إلى قبل فترة، ما أدري لو للحين
بس إلى قبل فترة تسلا كانت ما تبيع في تكساس
مع أن إيلون ماسك له علاقات ممتازة في تكساس
ما كان يبيع لأن تكساس كانت ترفض أنه يدخل بدون وكيل
مع أنه «سبيس إكس» كل شغلها في تكساس
بوكا تشيكا والمكان مَال «سبيس إكس»
وعلاقاته مع الحاكم ممتازة لكن ما قدر يبيع
الحين مش متأكد صراحة، بس قبل كان هذا النظام، ما كان يبيع فيها
فهو بالنسبة له نقطته هذه جدًّا مشدد عليها
لا السعودية تجاوزت مسألة الوكيل لها الظاهر كم سنة
بس أيش اللي يخليك تقول أن «لوسيد»
المفترض أنها تطلع تصير شركة خاصة مش عامة
أيش اللي يفرق معها السعودية؟
شوف اللي يفرق معها السعودية
أن أول شيء أنت عندك أيش هدفك من الشركة؟
أنت هل تبي تسوي منها فلوس ولا تبيها تنتج لك
ولا تساعدك في الوصول لهدف؟
أنت أغلب الظن تبغى الاثنين
الشركة مش قاعدة توصل هدفها الأساسي اللي هو قاعدة تنتج سيارات
انسى الربحية، الربحية خليها على صوب، لكن أنت مش قادر تصنع
المدير التنفيذي للـ«لوسيد»
تقريبًا حصل على خمسة من أصل ستة شرائح
خمسة من ستة شروط كان المفروض ينفذها عشان يستحق مكافأته
في قمتها كانت توصل 220 مليون دولار
وعُقب كانت أقل بكثير لأن السهم انهار من هذيك الفترة
الحين 5.5 أو 4.5 دولار على سعر السهم تقريبًا
وهو صار هناك خمسين أو ...؟
كان يوصل أعتقد قريب خمسة وسبعين إلى ثمانين دولار
فثروته الحين صارت عشرات الملايين
لكن السؤال هو كيف راح يقدر ينتج؟
أنت عندك كل يوم والثاني، مو كل يوم والثاني عفوًا
بس أنه كل فترة وفترة يعطيك نوع سيارة جديدة
وأنت القديمة ما تقدر تسويهم على نطاق عالي
يعني إيلون سوَّى حركتين
جاب لك النموذج «أس» أول شي بدأ فيها، طورها، وقدر ينتجها
عقب جاب لك النموذج «أس»
كانوا على أساس أنه سيارة غالية لكن هامش مرتفع
وهي اللي بدأت فيهم «لوسيد» على أساس المفروض نأخذ هامش مرتفع
بس المشكلة «لوسيد» قاعدة تبيع بخسارة
كان المفترض أنها تكون بربحية عالية؟
كان المفروض تكون بربحية عالية بس «لوسيد» قاعدة تبيع بخسارة
تخسر أظن 250-300 ألف دولار على كل سيارة تبيعها
بقيمة 100 ألف دولار
إي مبلغ ضخم، قاعدة تخسر مبالغ ضخمة
فبدال ما أنت تشوف لي طريقة تسوي لي فيها سيارة أرخص
تقدر تبيعها بشكل واسع
قاعدة كل فترة تنزل لك سيارة جديدة
عندك الـ«آير» وعندك الـ«آير...» أيش اسمها
«دريم»
عندك الـ«دريم» وعندك الحين الآن نزلت الـ «قرافيتي»
اللي هي الـ «أس.يو.في» الكبيرة
ومشكلة بعض السيارات هذه
أن حتى لو تبي إدارة ثانية ما تقدر تصلحها، ليش؟
إيلون كان يقول جزء من صناعة السيارة الممتازة أن تكون صناعتها سهلة
حتى لو كان الهامش مالها يكون جيد، لكن صناعتها لازم تكون سهلة
إذا الصناعة صعبة
صعب عليك جدًّا أنك تأخذ السيارة هذه، وتقدر تنشرها على نطاق واسع
أيش قصدك؟
يعني مثال، إيلون أذكر فيه واحد مختص بعملية تفكيك السيارات وتركيبها
فدائمًا يأخذ هذا ويقيم
كم تقريبًا يكلف صنع السيارة مع الشغل، كم يكلف؟
فجاب نموذج «ثري» وفتحها
قال هذه أسهل سيارة أنا ركَّبتَها في ذاكرتي
أسهل سيارة فكّكتها في آخر في سنين عمري يمكن
قال تكلفتها كلها بحسبتي ما تتجاوز...
ما أتذكر الرقم 25 أو 20 ألف دولار يمكن
تسلا كم تبيعها؟ تبيعها أقل شيء حوالي 50 أو 70 ألف
أنت عندك الهامش عليه 50% أو 40%
طبعًا تنزل بين فترة وفترة، لكن على الأقل 30%
متوسط الهامش على باقي السيارات
ما يتعدى 10 إلى 12% ومرات أقل بعد
السيارات غير تسلا؟
السيارات بشكل عام الأخرى
حوالي ما بين 10-15 يمكن يوصل 14%
لكن ما يتعدى أكثر، صعب جدًّا يتعدى
تسلا قاعدة تأخذ 30-40 سيارة
«هرتزِ» لما رجعت في 2022
لما أسعار الفائدة قامت ترتفع، تنزل وتنزل في الأسعار، ليش؟
لأنها تقدر، وربحانة في كل الحالات، ما قاعدة تبيع بخسارة
لكن هذا الشيء ضغط على جماعة «لوسيد»
اللي هو نزل شوي قبل فترة، لكن بعد مو ملحق
كم بينزل؟ هو أصلًا قاعد يبيع بخسارة، كم بيعمقها؟
فبرأيي أنا، تحتاج مراجعة عملية الإنتاج كاملة
هل السيارة فعلًا صعبة التصنيع؟
تروح تلغيها، وتروح تصنع لي سيارة جديدة من الصفر
شيء ممكن سهولة تصنيعه، شيء تشوف أنك ممكن تبيعه بشكل...
وشيء ممكن تنتجه الأهم بسعر معقول
والعملية هذه المستثمرين ما راح يصبرون عليها
الشركة كاملة تقعد بدون أرباح وبدون عائد إيرادات لفترة طويلة صعبة جدًّا
حلها الوحيد أن الحكومة تصبر عليها
خذوها خاصة، وغير لي المدير التنفيذي جيب واحد يقدر
لو المدير التنفيذي شاف...، أنا ما أشوف أنه يقدر صراحة
لكن إذا شافوا أنه ما عنده القدرة أنه يسوي العملية هذه
يجيبون أحد بدالة، ويباشر العملية هذه حتى لو تبدأها من الصفر
لكن إذا ما بتبدأها الحين، متى بتبدأها؟
لأنك صار لك سنتين على نفس الحالة، مو قاعد تتغير
أيش اللي يخلي...
هل تسلا كانت هي اللي كسرت القواعد، وصارت قادرة أنها تربح؟
لأنه قبل تسلا ما كان في شركة سيارات قدرت تنجو
أو أنها تكون موجودة حتى أصلًا
وهي الشركة الوحيدة مع فورد اللي ما أفلست
صح
فيمكن أنها استثناء
تسلا اللي قدرت أنها تسوي هذا الشكل من أشكال السيارات الكهربائية
«لوسيد» هي مجرد من الشركات اللي تخسر
هذا المجال ليس مكانًا للربح، ولا مكانًا للنجاح، تسلا كانت استثناء
هل هو ممكن
شوف تسلا كانت الاستثناء
لكن تسلا بدأت الموضوع
لأنها كانت أول وحدة تتبنى بطاريات «الليثيوم ايون»
اللي هي كانت في فترة من الفترات كانت غالية جدًّا
بعدما صارت تكلفتها رخيصة وتكلفة صنعها رخيصة
قام إيلون استثمر فيه
أنت عارف قصة تسلا
عفوًا قام يجرب السيارات مع الاثنين اللي هم مؤسسين تسلا الأصليين
«إبر هارد» والثاني ما أتذكر اسمه
فدخلت معاهم، وقاموا يجربون شافوا أن فعلًا تكلفتها رخيصة
وبدأوا بالـ«رودستار» أول وحدة التي لو تروح إلى أمريكا معارضهم
تحصلها موجودة بس كنموذج أو كتصميم فبعدما بدأوا بهذه
إيلون...، أرد أعيد لك النقطة اللي قلت لك إياها قبل شوي
أنه بدأ بالنموذج «إكس» و«إس» على أساس أنه هامش ربح عالي
بعدين صناعة السيارة أخذ له وقت طويل على فكرة إلى ما صنع النموذج «ثري»
ووعد في بدايتها أنها تكون 25 ألف دولار
لأنه عارف تكلفتها بتكون رخيصة
لأن الصناعة نفسها، قبل شوي تكلمت يمكن
تقول لي السيارة مثلًا بلاستيك في بعض الأماكن
والله الدريشة خفيفة تدخل واجد هواء
فعلًا هذه الأشياء كانت موجودة
بس أنت أهم شي دخل أو طلع شيء للناس
طلع شيء وبعدين اشتغل، شوف وين تقدر تخفض التكاليف
بعض الأمور كانت...، أذكر على الأقل قصة واحدة كانوا متكلمين عنها
يقول لك على النموذج «ثري» إيلون زار بشكل عشوائي المصنع
سأل مجموعة، قال لهم تحطوهم طبقة فوق البطارية وطبقة تحت البطارية
أو تحت هيكل السيارة، قال هي أيش الهدف منها؟
قالوا تخفض الصوت
قال: أنا مو مقتنع أنها تخفض الصوت، هذه كم قيمتها؟
قالوا حوالي 900 أو 800 دولار، شيء زي كذا
قال: اصنع لي سيارة بدونها، خلنا نجرب
صنع سيارة بدونها، طلع فيها، وقال: ما أحس بشيء، مثلما هي
أقول لك شيء، الغيها من الخط
خفَّض سعر السيارة 800 -900 دولار
فأقول لك: هي بعدين يبي لها واحد مثل إيلون
مستعد يخفض التكاليف بشكل حاد جدًّا، ومستعد يجرب أشياء
هل إيلون الوحيد؟ لا، غيره بيسوون فلوس بعد
لكن مثلما تفضلت قبل شوي، عدد المنافسين الحين صار ضخم جدًّا
لدرجة حتى الصين صارت ما تعطي أي إضافات
أو فوائد للشركات الجديدة اللي تفتح، قبل كان في عطاء
ومعفي من الضرائب ومعفي من التكلفة الفلانية
أعطيهم برنامج كامل كمختص، ما يحضرني كامل الحين
لمن؟
الشركات الصينية
الشركات الصينية اللي تسوي سيارات كهرباء
تسوي سيارات كهربائية
بعد فترة من كثر ما صار فيه ازدحام، صار فيه أكثر من 700 شركة صينية
أغلبهم يشتغلون في الصين ما يصدرون برَّة
إلا يمكن «نيو» اللي توها بدأت وغيرها كمان واحدة «بي واي دي»
فوقفوا قالوا خلاص ما عندكم أي...
واحنا نشجع أن الشركات ما تفتح لأن السوق صار متشبع
ليش؟
خلاص قال في عندك 700 شركة عندك، كم بتصنع؟
خلاص عندنا ما يكفي
احنا نؤمن أنه ضمن هذه الـ 700 شركة الموجودة البعض سينجح
والغالبية العظمى ستفشل، وهذا نظام السوق الطبيعي، ما عندك مشكلة
هذا في الصين؟
هذا في الصين
الحين «ريفيان» أيش اللي عندنا؟
احنا عندنا «ريفيان» و«لوسيد» و«تسلا» و«نيو»
صح
فيه واحدة هذه اللي فيها..
أي واحدة زائد؟ عندك «الهامر إي.في» جالسين الآن يحولون
أنا أبغى الشركات الكهربائية...
«بيور» كهربائية، أعتقد هذول الأساسيات
مين اللي ربحان فيهم؟
«تسلا»
لا كله...
مين الخسران؟ الحين «لوسيد» خسرانة
الباقيين كلهم خسرانين؟
شوف كل أحد جالس يخسر إلى حد ما
لكن «لوسيد» أكثر واحدة جالسة تخسر فيهم
تكلفة صناعة السيارات عالية جدًّا، والحين جاية السعودية على فكرة
بكمية دعم هائلة بالمليارات، كم ما أعرف بالضبط
وكيف؟ على الأرض أو على الماء أو على الكهرباء على الأمور هذه
الحين المشكلة ما نعرفها في السعودية، بتقدر تربح ولا لا؟
لكن السؤال هو، لنفرض أنها قدرت تربح مع الدعم هذا كله
الدعم هذا المفروض يكون غير مستدام، المفروض يدوم لفترة بسيطة
من بعد الفترة هذه أنت المفروض خلاص تبدأ توقف على رجلك
المفروض السعودية خلاص بعد فترة تبدأ تسمح للشركات الخارجية
أنها تيجي تنافس «لوسيد»
عشان تثبت نجاحها، هل أنت فعلًا ناجحة وللا لا؟
فالسؤال هو هل بتقدر هي مع النظام الحالي؟
هذا التحدي المفروض هي...
هل هو منطقي لدول الخليج أنها تصنع سيارات؟
الحين أنا أقول لك السعودية عندها شركتين سيارات
واحدة مستثمرين فيها اللي هي «لوسيد»
صح
و«سير» اللي هي شركة بنتها من الصفر
والمفترض أنها تبدأ ببيع السيارات الظاهر في 2025
وعندنا «ربدان» في الإمارات
صح
هل منطقي لدول الخليج أنها تصنع سيارات؟
شوف هو يعتمد أنت أيش تبغى؟
كدول خليج هي أيش هدفها من الموضوع أساسًا؟
هل هدفها يكون في مجرد سيارة إماراتية؟
لو هذا ممكن تشتري الغالبية مثلما السعودية سوت في أي حصة وخلاص
لو تبغى تسوي فلوس
شخصيًّا ما أشوف أن السيارات هي الحل الأمثل أنك تسوي فلوس منها
مثال، أنت الحين لما تصنع السيارة، أيش هدفك منها؟
كيف تعرف أنك أنت ناجح ولا لا؟
في البداية ممكن أنك تعطي حوافز، وممكن تعطي دعم وتوفر
على أمل مثلما قلنا أن الشركة توقف على ريلها إلى حدٍ ما
لكن كيف تعرف إذا أنت فعلًا بتنجح وللا لا؟
عن طريق التصدير، هل بتقدر تصدر وللا لا؟
وهذا اللي يفيدك هل أنت فعلًا يفيد اقتصادك وللا لا؟
هل أنت قادر تصدر للدول الأخرى؟
أنك تصدر للدول الأخرى
معناه أنت مو قاعد تنافس بس السوق المحلي اللي عندك
أنت تنافس كل أحد
أنت منافسك «تسلا» أنت منافسك «هيونداي»
أنت منافسك «تويوتا» و«نيسان»
كل أحد، لأن كل أحد في النهاية جالس يحول
هل أنت تقدر تنافسهم؟ هذا واحد
والشيء الثاني: ليش أنت تبغى تنافسهم؟
أنا أفهم وجهة نظر دول الخليجية أن جزء كبير من الاستيراد
اللي عندنا من السيارات
وأنك مجرد تخفض الاستيراد ناتج القومي عندك يرتفع لو أنت تصنعها محليًّا
لكن السؤال هو، هل بنقدر نصنع سيارات فعلًا ملائمة للسوق المحلي
وبتكلفة مقبولة للسوق المحلي بدون دعم؟
لأن مع الدعم أنت ما سويت شيء
ممكن الدعم نمشيه كم سنة ما عندك مشكلة
لكن على المدى الطويل ما راح ينفعك واجد
ليش؟
خلاص أنت لازم توقف
لمتى بتدعم الشركة؟ لازم توقف على رجلها في النهاية
وجهة نظري أن دول الخليج مؤمنة أنها تقدر تنتج
أن تأخذ شركات السيارات هذه عفوًا
أن تخليها تنتج سيارات ملاءمة للسوق المحلي مستقبلًا
هذا إذا يبغونها من ناحية استثمارية
ما يبغونها من ناحية أن مثلما تقول
أن ما يصير احنا دولة مثلًا دول كبيرة وغنية، وما تكون لنا شركة سيارات
ممكن يشتروا مثلما السعودية اشترت «لوسيد»
الإمارات ممكن تشتري حصة في أي شركة ثانية، وتسويها وخلاص
بس أرد وأقول لك عملية المنافسة وعملية الصناعة والإنتاج صعبة جدًّا
بالذات لما تكون شركة حكومية اللي تمسك
ليش؟
عفوًا لما مثلًا الحكومة هي اللي...
لازم يكون عندك واحد
تبغى شركات مثل هذه تنجح
لازم يكون عندك أحد في القطاع الخاص مش بس متخصص
يكون يعني مثلما تقول
أحاول بس أجيب لك إياها بالطريقة اللي ممكن تكون منطقية
غير جلسته
لا، شوف إيلون مش الوحيد اللي نجح
كثيرين نجحوا غيره مش بس موضوع السيارات الكهرباية
موضوع السيارات بشكل عام
وكثيرين ينجحون غيره
لكن لما يكون عندك واحد، مش بس يكون مدير تنفيذي
مجموعة حتى كبار المستثمرين الموجودين في الشركة أساسًا
لما يكونون معاك، معاهم هدف واحد أنهم يبغون يربحون لنفسهم
الواحد يكون لنفسه يبغى يربح غير عن الحكومة
الحكومة في النهاية جيبها وسيع
شركة خسرت سنين طويلة ما عندها مشكلة، مثل «لوسيد» الحين
لو «لوسيد» كانت مملوكة تمامًا للشركات يمكن سعرها بيكون أقل بكثير
أنت عندك 65% تملكها السعودية ما قاعد يُناع منها ولا شيء
الهبوط هذا كله من الـ35%
والسعودية تمت تزيد على فكرة بين فترة وفترة
لو كانت مملوكة فعليًّا للقطاع الخاص كامل
كان شفت وضعها أسوأ بكثير، لكن السعودية هي اللي ماسكتها
فأنت الحين إذا تبغى شركة مثل هذه تنجح
تخليها عند ناس لهم مثلما تقول حافز لنفسهم هم أن الشركة هذه تنجح
في القطاع أن الشركة تكون مملوكة حكومية هذا شيء صعب تسويه
لأنه مش فلوسي، فلوس الحكومة
خسرت أو ما خسرت، أنا في نهاية راتبي يمشي
ولو كنت في حال «لوسيد»
بالفعل أخذت خياراتي، خيارات المساهمين تقريبًا
خمسة من ستة منهم
خلاص ممكن أكمل بالطريقة اللي أشوفها مناسبة إلى أجلٍ مسمى
وأشوف أيش بيستوي بعدين
فالعملية ما أقول لك مستحيلة، لا مش مستحيلة أبدًا، ولكن صعبة
وجهة نظري أنه ممكن الموارد اللي عنا ممكن تحطها في شي آخر
ممكن يكون السوق فيه أقل نضوجًا
ممكن أنت تأخذ المبالغ هذه تنتج هذا إذا هدفك اقتصادي
مثلما قلنا إذا هدفك أنك أنك يكون لك اسم وسمعة
هذا موضوع آخر، اسمه سمعه في المجال
أيش الأماكن الثانية اللي أقل تشبعًا؟
ممكن أي صناعة أخرى
مثلًا احنا عندنا في أبو ظبي عنا اهتمام كبير بشركات الروبوتيكس
بالشركات اللي تنتج الدرونز، والشركات اللي تنتج الأمور هذه
لأن ه مهما كان عندك دول بسيطة اللي قاعدة تصنعها
فأ بوظبي أيش سوَّت؟
قامت استقطبت بعض الشركات هذه أعطتها حوافز
بعضها اشترت فيها حصص، وبعضها ما اشترت فيها حصص
قالت تعالوا انتجوا عنَّا احنا بنعطيكم اللي تبونه
يعني يبغون يأسسون نظام بيئي كامل للشركات هذه
أنها تجي تنتج بالإمارات
هذا موجود على فكرة ضمن السياسة الموجودة لوزارة الذكاء الاصطناعي
الذكاء الاصطناعي
أيش المجالات اللي احنا نبي نستقطبها، ونبني نجيبها؟
مجالات البرمجة، ومجالات الروبوتكس، ومجالات الذكاء الاصطناعي
والأمور هذه
هذه كلها بعدها في البدايات، ما وصلت لمرحلة..
شوف كيف الحين الشركات كلها تحاول تنافس «أوبن إيه آي» بأي طريقة
كل أحد قاعد يروح يحاول يطالب يأخذ
اللي يقدر عليه من الرقائق الموجودة عند «إنيفيديا»
الـ«H109» و الـ«A100»
عشان يدربون النماذج اللغوية الخاصة فيهم
النماذج اللي هي المثل «شات جي بي تي» يدربونها عليها...
فهذه المجالات بعدها جديدة
الحين ما أتكلمان احنا ننافس في موضوع «نموذج اللغة الكبير» هذا موضوع ثاني
احنا عندنا في أبو ظبي على فكرة
أعتقد اسمه «فالكون إيه آي»
فأقول لك عندنا وبادئين في النظام هذا
ولكن هذه مجالات بعدها توها في بداياتها، بالذات الروبوتيكس
طيب خلني أتحدى فكرتك شوي
قُل لي
أن التقنيات اللي تقول عليها أنها معقدة
وأن السيارات تقنية أو صناعتها أسهل
مش بالضبط
يعني ما فيها هذاك...
التعقيد يمكن يكمن في إذا تبغى تحط قيادة ذاتية أو لا
في النظام اللي تبغى تحطه في السيارة يعني هنا
بس في صناعة السيارة يعني أبسط، واحد
اثنين: أن فيه سهلاك عالي جدًّا داخليًّا
فأنت إذا بعت على مستوى الخليج يمديك تنجح بشركة سيارة مقبولة إلى حد ما
أنك تقدر تفيد
عندك في السعودية لحالها في ستة عشر مليون سيارة، فيمديك
اثنين أنه فيه سوق
ثلاثة: أن التقنيات اللي تقول عليها معقدة جدًّا
واللي يفهم فيها قليل جدًّا على مستوى العالم ونادر
واللي بيترك «أوبن إيه آي» ويجي في أبو ظبي، ولا في الرياض
واضح أن هو من أقل الناس مهارةً هناك
لأنه إذا فاهم المفترض أني في «مايكروسوفت» ولا «أوبن إيه آي»
ولا في «إكس إيه آي» ولا أي شيء
برضو هناك في تحدي عالي جدًّا في استقطاب المهارة
في الدول المتقدمة هذه
فما بيجيك إلا الرَّدي
أبي أتوقع أن أقلهم كفاءة، إذا بحطها بتسمية أحسن
أربعة: أن واضح الآن أن أمريكا لن تسمح
طلبت السعودية من «إنفيديا»
أنها تبغى تشتري رقائق، ورفضت أمريكا، مش «إنفيديا»
«إنفيديا» وافقت وعلى أن العملية تتم
جاءت أمريكا، وقالت: لا، ممنوع. بحجة أمن قومي
اثنين: قبل كم يوم أجبروا صندوق أرامكو، كان مستثمر في شركة...
«فنشر كابتل» تحت أرامكو أنه يبيع حصة من شركة «إيه آي»
بالقوة لأن الاستثمار هنا خطر
صح
فإذا دخلنا هذا المكان والمعترك بهدف اسقطاب، برضو ما هو سهل
فبالعكس أحسه أكثر حدة من نفس السيارات
بس لازم تأخذ فرق بين الاثنين
أول شيء السيارات تتطلب صناعة على مستوى عالي جدًّا
أنت بتربح في صناعة السيارات
لازم تنتج على مستوى واسع عمليات ضخمة
عشرات الآلاف ومئات الآلاف من السيارات تبي تنتج
عشان فعلًا توصل لمرحلة أنك أنت..
العملية هذه نفسها صعبة جدًّا بشكل...
على كلام إيلون كان يسميها إنتاج الجحيم
يوم كان ينام في المصنع أيام النموذج «ثري»
الأمور الأخرى أمور البرمجة، عندك في الروبوتكس عندك منتج صح
لكن صناعتها، ما أبغى أقول لك أنها سهلة، لا مش سهلة
لكن نقطتي هي على الموضوع اللي أنت قلته قبل شوي
بالنسبة لموضوع أنك أنت ما تقدر أنك تجيب ناس وتيجب الردي
هذا أنا أختلف معاه تمامًا
تختلف؟
جدًّا
في ناس شوف ما تجيب أفضل الأفضل
«سام ألتمان» ما راح يجيك، لكن في ناس كثيرين غير...
بالذات ناس عندك في دول أخرى ما حصَّلوا حقهم أنهم يروحون
عندك في الصين، وعندك في الهند، وعندك غيرهم
ناس أصلًا، ما أقول لك عندهم الخبرات هذه كلها
لكن عندهم الرغبة والدافع أنه يطورون الأمور هذه بس يحتاجون دعم
وبالذات في أبو ظبي صار في دعم لكثير من هؤلاء
وحتى بعضهم جاؤوا من أمريكا ومن أوربا وغيره ويفتحون عنا احنا
قالوا نقدم لكم الدعم، ونقدم لكم التمويل، ونقدم لكم المكان
وباشروا شغلكم
ابدأوا طوروا لنا المجالات هذه، وطوروا لنا المنتجات هذه
طبعًا بعضهم خدمات أو برمجيات، وبعضهم يكون لك منتجات
المنتجات عمليته شوي أصعب بيأخذ له وقت، لكن أصلًا احنا بادئين فيه
أبو ظبي سواءً حتى من الأمور العسكرية أو غير العسكرية
فيه تطوير للدرون عندنا موجود في أبو ظبي حاليًا
بالنسبة لموضوع نماذج اللغة احنا طورناه وموجود في أبو ظبي
طبعًا لا يصل لمرتبة «أوبن إيه آي» هذا أكيد، لكنه بالفعل موجود
وموضوع الـ«إتش 100» والـ«أيه 100» أنا على قناعة أنه سيُحل
وفعليًّا في عندنا احنا رقائق لكن مش بالحجم المطلوب
احنا طالبين زيادة، وحتى أنتم عندكم
لكن احنا طالبين أكثر بكثير حتى نوصل لطموحاتنا
قبل فترة الصين طلعت نموذج لغة كبير
صُدمت أمريكا بالذات أنه كيف قدروا...
عفوًا وصنعوا رقائق
ما أبغى أقول لك نفس قوة «إنفيديا»
نفس الـ«إتش 100» اللي عند «إنفيديا» لكن مقارب جدًّا
قالوا احنا مانعين عليهم الوصول للرقائق هذه
كيف قدروا يصنعوا الوحدة هذه؟
لكن قدروا
وعلاقة الصين بالإمارات والسعودية ممتازة فممكن تسويها وتأخذها
فأن أمريكا تمنعك أو تحاول توقف تطورك، ما راح يمنعك تمامًا
راح يبطئ العملية بلا شك
لكن يمنعك تمامًا، أنا أشوف أن الشيء هذا شبه مستحيل
بس إنه معقد، هذا قصدي
ترى غير «إنفيديا» فيه عندك «إيه أم دي» و«إنتل»
وعندك...، يعني شركات المعالجات كثيرة في العالم
بس مش مثل «إنفيديا»
بس ما أحد عارف، إي فما بالك إنك تبغى الشركات الأمريكية ما هي قادرة
فتبغى الصين اللي هي متأخرة في صناعة المعالجات
أنها تروح تنافس «إنفيديا» في هذه المسألة
فهذا قصدي أنا
الصين مش بذاك التأخير ترى في صناعة المعالجات
هل هي مثل «إنفيديا» لا
لا عشرة سنين عن «إنفيديا»
ترى أقول لك هي راح تأخرك، هي بلا شك أنها راح تأخرك
أنت ما تقدر توصل للركب هذا بالسرعة الحالية
لكن هل توقفك ولا تقول لا خلاص خليني أوقف؟
لا مستحيل، أنك توصل متأخرًا خيرًا من ألَّا تصل
صحيح
فخلاصة الكلام أنه بس عشان نقارن...
السيارات عمليتها صعبة، وصناعتها صعبة جدًّا
لأنك لازم عشان تربح فيها تصنعها على مستوى واسع
والسيارات في النهاية عندك بديل، الروبوتات ما عندك بديل
بتضطر تأخذها من هناك
وأنت معرّض لعملية أنه هل راح يسمحوا لك تأخذها وللا لا؟
فأنت أفضل لك ولأمنك الداخلي أن أنت تصنعها داخليًّا، كثر ما تقدر
السيارات مش مضطر تصنعها داخليًّا
كل دول عالم جالسة تصنعها
تقدر تأخذ من الصين بـ40 ألف
وتقدر تأخذها بأمريكا نصف مليون، أنت شو تبيها موجود
لكن الروبوتات ما أحد بيبيعك إلا اللي هو مستعد يتركها عشانك
ما راح يعطيك أفضل تقنية موجودة عنده
الحين يقول لك خذها على طبق من ذهب
بالذات أمور لما تكون مثل «إيه آي»
اللي تمس الأمن القومي مثلما شفنا إدعاءات إدارة بايدن
أنها تمس الأمن القومي
فبالتالي يقول لك أنا أطالبك أنك تبيع ولًّا أمنعك تشتري الشغلة الفلانية
فتحدي، طيب الحين واضح أنه اللي جالسة تسويه دول الخليج
عندي الحين مثال الإمارات والسعودية
اللي هو في محاولة بناء شركات للسيارات
أو حتى الاهتمام بالذكاء الاصطناعي وغيره
أنها في محاولة للمسير في التخلص من الاعتماد على النفط
صحيح
بس الحين إذا طلعنا، وأخذنا كل دول الخليج
كلهم من القديم، كلهم يقولون احنا نبغى نتخلص من النفط
وين تشوف دول الخليج مجتمعه ككتلة
قدرت توصل في هذا الهدف الطموح؟
لما نقول دول الخليج الأفضل تقسمهم إلى عدة أجزاء
عندك الإمارات والسعودية في صوب
اللي هم بادئين في العملية، في عملية التطوير وعملية التغيير
عندك قطر اللي هي فعليًّا نقدر نقول إنها ما تحتاج يمكن تغير كثير
طبعًا بادئة أقل عن غيرها
وما تحتاج فعليًّا صراحة بحكم أنها دولة غنية جدًّا
بالذات النفط يعني النفط، عفوًا الغاز بالذات أنه عندها منه كمية ضخمة
والتوقعات أنه راح يستمر الطلب عليها أقل شيء ثلاثين أو أربعين سنة قادمة
عقب عندك البحرين اللي هي اختصارًا تقدر تقول معتمد على السعودية
إلى حد كبير
وفي النهاية عندك آخر شيء عمان والكويت
كلنا معتمدين على..
ما شرحت عمان والكويت، أيش شفيهم؟
عمان والكويت
عمان معتمد على النفط، والكويت معتمد على النفط بشكل كبير
وإلى الحين التنويع ما صار بحجم أنه بالطريقة اللي...
تشوف أنت في الإمارات والسعودية
بالذات في الكويت ما عندهم إلى الحين ما في أي تغيير
مثلما هم بالنظام
خاصةً مع موضوع مجلس الأمة وغيرها
شوي الموضوع هذا معطل العملية
بالنسبة لعمان ترى تعول عن نفط حالها حال غيرها
لكن في السنين الأخيرة بالذات من مسك «السلطان هيثم»
قام بإصلاحات كثيرة، منها يمكن ما أدري لو سامعين عنها
لكن باع جزء من أصول عمان لشركات صينية، عشان يكسب سيولة
لأن وقتها كانت ديون عمان واصلة لمرحلة عالية جدًّا
والحبن، الحمد لله، بسبب ارتفاع النفط
والدخل اللي جاءهم من الضريبة المضافة
قدروا يسددوا عدد من ديونهم
حوالي 2.5 أو 3.5 مليار دولار تقريبًا سددوه في الفترة الأخيرة
بس تخفيض حجم الديون
اقتصادها الصحي وشركات التقييمات الائتمانية رفعتها
والضريبة عندهم 5%؟
5% لكن 24% يقدمون ضريبة الدخل
ضريبة الدخل
من 2024
في سبتمبر، 2022 وزير الاقتصاد عندهم، ووزير المالية
قال أنه...
لأن سألوه، هل أنتم ناويين تستمرون بالعملية هذه؟
قال: نعم، ما راح توقف
كيف بتكون؟ ما أحد يعرف
لأن هي بالعادة ضريبة الدخل كيف تكون؟
تكون بنظام الشرائح
دخلك من صفر إلى 20 ألف ريال أو درهم، ما تدفع ولا شيء
من 20 ألف إلى 40 الف ريال تدفع مثلًا 5%
من أربعين إلى هذا...، تدفع 15%
100 وفوق تدفع عليهم 50%
ما ينطبق على الدخل كامل، على كل شريحة
يحسبوا لك أنت 5% تدفع من هذه الشريحة
10% من هذه و10% من هذه وآخر شيء عليك هذا الكثر
فبالتالي راح يستثنون...
وهي على فكرة
الضريبة أكثر عدلًا من ضريبة الخدمة المضافة
ضريبة الخدمة المضافة أكثر ضريبة ظالمة
ليش؟
أنا وأنت نروح الجمعية
أنا دخلي 50 ألف في السنة، وأنت دخلك 10 مليون في السنة
مشترياتنا بـ 500 درهم، أنا أدفع 5% وأنت تدفع 5%
مين جالس يدفع أكثر من إجمالي دخله؟ أنا قاعد أدفع أكثر
أنت بالنسبة لك حسيت فيها؟ ما تحس فيها
أنا بالنسبة لي تهمني كثير، أحس فيها
تعتبر الضريبة خلينا نقول أكثر كسلًا أو أنها الأسهل تطبيقًا
وهي شيء منطقي وعقلاني
أن دول الخليج تبدأ فيها لأنها الأسهل تطبيقًا، وهي مرحلة خطوة البداية
خلينا نطبقها، ونشوف كيف، وتطبيقها سهل، وتقدر تتابعها بسهولة
وكان جزء من تطبيقها اللي يبغون يعرفون دخل الشركات كم
لأن بالنهاية أنت كشركة لازم تبلغ الحكومة أو هيئة الضرائب عندك
كم قاعد تدخل؟ كم قاعد تربح؟
فهذا يعطيهم رؤية على أيش اللي قاعد يصير في السوق فعليًّا
فتم تطبيقه على هذا الأساس
بعدين أنتوا السعودية بعد في سبيل إصلاح اللي صار عندكم
رفعتوه إلى 15%
ليش السعودية بالذات رفعته 15%؟
اللي صار وقت كورونا
النفط ضُرب بالتالي احنا مثلما يصير بالعادة بكل السنين
لما النفط في سنة 2014 وقبلها صار
لما النفط ينزل النفط يصير في عملية شد الحزام
نحاول شوية نخفض مصاريفنا
على أساس الدخل اللي راح يجينا ويغطي دولنا ما بيكون بالقوة هذه
خاصة أن أبو ظبي، اقسم بس أبو ظبي ودبي
لأن الاقتصادين مختلفين تمامًا
أبو ظبي آخر أرقام سنة 2020 تعتمد 70% على النفط من ناحية الدخل
السعودية حوالي 80% إلى 85% والكويت 80%-85%
قطر وعمان نفس الشيء، والبحرين طبعًا نفس الشيء
الوحيدة اللي مختلفة هي دبي
دبي 70% من دخلها يجي من الرسوم والخدمات والأمور هذه
فنرجع لموضوعنا، أيش كنت جالس أقول؟
كنت تبغى تفصّل دول الخليج لأني أنا حطيتها كتلة واحدة
عفوًا موضوع 15%
إي 15%
معليش سامحني شوي
لا بالعكس، نرجع نقفل النوافذ
بالضبط نقفل النوافذ وحدة وحدة
فليش السعودية فتحت 15%؟
تاريخيًّا قبل رؤية الأمير محمد بن سلمان
السعودية والكويت أكثر دولتين عندهم الدخل المتبقي يُصرف خارج دولهم
أيش تقصد؟
أنت سعودي وراتبك في الشهر 20 ألف
أساسياتك 7 إلى 8 الاف
عندك أنت مستعد، تقول تبغى تحفظ مثلًا تحط عندك في البنك
3 إلى 4 الاف
صار عندك 8 إلى 9 آلاف دخل تبغى تصرفه لمتعتك
ما في شيء في السعودية تسويه
هذا قبل رؤية... لأنه ما كان عندك شيء في السعودية تسويه
بالكويت نفس الشيء، أغلب المبالغ هذه تصرفها برة
يا على سفر يا على تروح تشتري لك كماليات
فالمبالغ هذه تُصرف برة
فكرة السعودية كانت، أنا عندي الشعب قاعد يأخذ فلوسه يصروفها برة
الحين بدأت كورونا، وأنا ما أبغى الشعب يطلع
علشان أحافظ عليهم من المرض، لا سمح الله، يجون ويتعبون
فليش ما أخذ عليهم 15%...؟
فكرة ضريبة القيمة المضافة مش بس تنويع مصدر الدخل
الفكرة أن أنا بأخذ مبلغ منك هذا، وبرجع أصرفه عليك
فإذا الدولة بتصرفه بشكل صحيح، عليها بالعافية
إذا بتصرفه بطرق مثلما تقول أنه يروح على الفاضي
يكون حرام، أنت ضيعت مبلغ مثل هذا
بس في الخليج عندنا ما صارت العملية هذه
فقامت السعودية أخذت 15%
وشفنا نتيجتها اليوم
شوف الـ«وينتر قاردن» وشوف الـ «البوليفارد سيتي»
هذا كله من وين جاء؟
هذه كلهم فلوس ضريبة القيمة المضافة، اللي أنتم كنتم تدفعونها
فالنتيجة صارت أيش؟ في آخر إفصاحات طلعت من إدارة السياحة في دبي
لأول مرة، مش لأول مرة لكن من بعد كورونا
بعدما صار في عملية تعافي كامل
عدد السعوديين اللي يزورون دبي قل
بنسبة بسيطة أعتقد حوالي 10% أو 9%
وبالإضافة إلى أن أرقام الصرف السعودي داخل السعودية من الفيزا وماستر كارد
يقول لك ارتفع أكثر بكثير عن السنين اللي قبل
فهذا نتيجة الإصلاحات العملية اللي تمت داخلها
وأنتم بعدكم في البداية ترى يعني عندكم...
أنا أقرأ عن كمية المشاريع الموجودة عندكم شيء مهول
هذا اللي الحين تبغى تسويه نفس الشيء عمان في اقتصادها
تبغى تأخذ من الناس
طريقة تنفيذ نظام ضريبة الدخل للحين مش واضحة
هم قالوا بنطبقها، لا أفصحوا عن الشرائح وللا كيف بتكون
لكن الفكرة هي كانت أنه خلنا نأخذها، ونرد نصرف فيها على البلد
نحاول نحفز، ونحاول نخلق بيئة ونظام بيئي
يسمح للشركات أنها تقدر توفر وظائف للناس والشعب
في الكويت طبعًا هذا الشيء ما صار
مجلس الأمة ما يزال على خلاف حتى في 2021 لما كانت الفائدة صفرية
كانت الديون أرخص بكثير من أنك ما تأخذ، كان اللي ما يحتاج يأخذ
أنت لو جاءت فترة أخذت، وتسلفت من أسواق الدين بالذات تقييم الكويت
تقييم الكويت عالي جدًّا بالمناصفة مع الإمارات وقطر
تقريبًا بينهم «دبل إيه بلس» أو «دبل إيه» بس أنه قريب جدًّا
تقدر تأخذ خله عندك، لو يأخذون الحين، ويحطونها في السندات الأمريكية
اللي هي تعتبر خطورتها قليلة تشوف تحصل 5% منها
لكن للأسف صارت في خلافات بينهم، وما تنفذ هذا
مع أنه الإمارات والسعودية وعمان والبحرين كلهم
يسمونها طباعة كلهم طبعوا السندات
وأخذوا الفلوس والحين كلهم قاعدين يستثمرون
فهذه جزء من الإصلاحات اللي قاعدة تتم بها
لما نقول اقتصاد خليجي صعب أنه نأخذه ككتلة وحدة؟
يختلف اختلاف كبير؟
غالبا كتلة وحدة
لأن في نهاية كلنا معتمدين على النفط
وكلنا عملاتنا مثبتة لكن باستثناء دبي
تقريبًا كلنا لحدٍ ما تقدر تقول أن احنا معتمدين عن نفس الأمور
ونواجه نفس المخاطر
صعب، أن ما أشوف أنه في شيء يبعد بيننا حاليًا
ولكن مستقبلًا راح يصير شوية انقسام
بالذات لو استمرت الكويت على وضعها الحالي بدون إصلاح
وأنا أتوقع وأتمنى أن يكون في إصلاح، إن شاء الله، بيكون في
لكن لو استمرت على النظام هذا
والإمارات السعودية استمروا من ناحية التحول إلى عملية اقتصاد غير نفطي
طبعًا الكلام يبي له وقت
ما بتعرف نتيجة الكلام هذا إلا بعد عشر سنوات تقريبًا
بتشوف أنه صارت مصادر الدخل مختلفة، وصارت الاعتمادات مختلفة
حتى تأثير النفط هبط أو ارتفع بتشوف أنه التأثيرات متباينة
الحين تأثيرات وحدة، كلنا نشد الحزام مع بعض
كلنا نفتح الصرف مع بعض
لكن بعدين بتشوف أنه إذا استمرينا بالتوجه هذا
بتشوف أنه هناك فصل كامل
مع أنه عمان قاعدة تلحق بالركب على فكرة، قاعد تطور وتعدل وتسوي
فالفكرة بتصير وقتها فكرة الاتحاد الخليجي
أو فكرة العملة الخليجية تصبح مستحيلة، وللا هي مستحيلة من الآن أصلًا؟
شوف العملة الخليجية، لو نرجع بس للأسباب
فكرتها بدأت في 2003 وتسكرت في 2010
ليش تسكرت في 2010؟
الخلاف، على الأقل الرسمي
كان أن الإمارات والسعودية كانوا مختلفين على وين يكون صندوق النقد
بالإضافة إلى أن عمان كانت رافضة لأسباب الخلفة
فجزء منها حسب ما قرأنا كان متعلق بالحفاظ على الهوية العمانية
والريال العماني والأمور هذه
ومن حقهم في النهاية
لكن السؤال الحين هل هو المفروض يرجع، ولا لا؟
الناس تختلف
عشان أرسم لك الصورة هذه
ممكن نتطلع على ثلاث نماذج ممكن أنها ترسم لنا صورة
عندك أول واحد اليورو
اللي هي مجموعة دول تربطها عملة واحدة، مش مربوطة بأي شيء
اليورو من المستفيد فيه اليوم؟ ألمانيا
ليش ألمانيا؟
أقوى اقتصاد، عفوًا نفهم بس عملية اليورو
اليورو أيش يسويه، أيش اللي يساعد بالضبط؟
يقلل تكلفة تحريك الأموال من دولة لأخرى تنخفض عندك بشكل كبير
تسمح بتحول الرؤوس البشرية
الناس يتحولون من وظيفة لوظيفة في كل مكان
يعتبر مواطن من أهل البلد
وتحوُّل الأموال
رأس المال البشري يتحرك من مكان لمكان بسهولة ويسر وما عندك أي مشكلة
أقوى اقتصاد اللي هو الألماني هو اللي قاعد يستفيد
هو أكثر واحد قاعد يصدر للدول الجوار
هو أكثر شخص يجيب الموظفين يجون يشتغلون عنده، وهو المستفيد
لأن عملة اليورو يعتبر شوي مرتفع يعتبر غالي
إيطاليا مثلًا إلى قبل يدخلون باليورو
كل كم سنة كانوا ينزلوا العملة، ويحفزون السياحة
بس مشكلة اليورو الحين أن النظام مصمم
هذا صراحة يحسب للناس اللي صمموه
يحسب إلى عملية أنه صعب جدًّا أحد يطلع منه
العملة بالذات بريطانيا كان أسهل
لأن بريطانيا طبعًا كان صعب جدًّا مثلما شفنا
بس كان أسهل لأن العملة نفسها كانت مختلفة
في 2012 في قمة الأزمة اليونانية
رئيس الوزارة الإيطالي ما أذكر مين كان، أعتقد «برلسكوني»
أتذكر طلب من البنك المركزي في إيطاليا
طلعوا لي دراسة، أيش راح يصير لو طلعنا من اليورو؟
سووا دراسة، أيش نتائجها؟
نتائجها كانت إفلاس إيطاليا، لأنها كانت مرهقة بالديون
إفلاس إيطاليا
احنا نقترح لو قمنا بالعملية هذه نطلع عملة جديدة اسمها يورو ليرة
لأن الليرة على أساس عملة في إيطاليا القديمة
يورو ليرة نربطها باليورو، واحد لواحد
بعد فترة نبدأ ننزل من قيمتها شوي شوي عشان نكون نقدر نحفز...
ولكن بحكم الاتفاقيات اللي تجمعنا مع اليورو
راح نواجه قضايا راح تدمرنا خمس إلى عشر أو سبع السنين الجاية
خلاصة الكلام احنا لا ننصح بالخروج من اليورو
مش لأنه اليورو مغري
لأن تكاليفه بتكسر ظهرنا أكثر مما احنا أصلًا متبهدلين
فما يقدرون، فأقول لك هو مصمم بطريقة أنه ما أحد يطلع منه
حتى لو أن إيطاليا ودها الحين تخفض سعر العملة
ما يقدرون يسوون شيء، هذا هو النموذج الأول
النموذج الثاني اللي هو نموذج دول مسوية اتحاد مشترك مثل اليورو
لكنهم رابطين عملتهم بعملة أخرى
اللي هو كأنه لو احنا بنسويها بنربط عملتنا بالدولار
عندك نموذج واحد يمكن يجي على البال، اللي هو النموذج الأفريقي
في عندك عدة دول أفريقية جينيا بيساو والسنقال وتوقو ويمكن غيرها
رابطين عملتهم باليورو
لكن مش على كيفهم
الكلام موجود من زمان، كانوا رابطين عملتهم بالعملة الفرنسية
وفرنسا فارضة الموضوع هذا عليهم
الموضوع هذا تقدر تقول أنه إلى حد ما ناجح
ما تقدر تقول ناجح 100% لأن أنت ما تعرف النظام كيف بيكون بدونه
لكن ناجح إلى حد ما، بحكم شيء واحد فقط
اللي هو أن العملة هذه «إكس أوه أف» اسمها
ضامنتها وزارة المالية الفرنسية
فتقول لك صار ما صار احنا نضمن أي حد يملكها
يتحول لليورو بسعر الصرف الفلاني
لكن نتيجة الاتفاقية هذه، أيش يستوي؟
كل الاحتياطات الأجنبية الموجودة عند دول أفريقية موجودة عند فرنسا
وما تعطيهم إياها على فكرة إلا بموافقة الوزارة
ليش؟ تقول لك تخلونها عندي غصبًا عنكم
لأنني ما أعرف أيش بيصير عندكم انقلابات
لو أخليها عندكم يجي واحد يسوي انقلاب ويأخذ الفلوس كلها
فخلوها عندي أنا
في مطالبات من كثير من الرؤساء الإفريقيين
أنه خلينا نتحكم في مصيرنا والأمور هذه، ولكن هذا موضوع آخر
النموذج الأخير اللي هو نموذج دول ربطت عملتها بوحدة فيهم
اللي هي بعد نموذج اليورو كان لكن قبل اليورو
من سنة 979 إلى 1999
كانت جميع الدول أو عدة دول أوربية رابطة عملتها بالمارك
المارك الألباني
اللي هي دخلت فيه بريطانيا فيما بعد
وكانت عملتها تم تقييمها على أساس شوية كانت غالية
ومسكهم «جورج سورس» وشاف أن الموضوع...
وقام راهن ضد العملة، وصار الانهيار، وصار ما صار
وما نجحت بالنهاية
لأنه كان عملية الدخول، الدول اللي ربطت عملاتها ربطتها بسعر كان يعتبر مرتفع
بالتالي إذا كان عندك تضخم أنت ما تقدر تسوي شيء
ما تقدر وما عندك قدرة، وما عندك مرونة أنك تلعب باقتصادك مثلما تبي
فالحين بعد هذه الثلاثة نرجع لموضوعنا
لو سوينا العملة الخليجية، أيش اللي رح يستوي؟
اليوم لو دولة من دول أوربا تبغى تطبع سندات ما تقدر على كيفها
لازم بموافقة البنك المركزي الأوربي
لازم حجم الدين إلى حجم الاقتصاد يكون على حد أقصى شيء معين
حجم دخلك لازم يكون شيء معين إلى نسبتك
عندنا احنا مين بيحلل الأمور هذه؟ صندوق النقل الخليجي
فهل احنا بنتفق أن يكون صندوق النقل الخليجي يسمح؟
عُمان قبل فترة كانت مضطرة تطبع بشكل شبه سنوي كذا مرة لأنها مجبورة
أيش بيستوي عقب؟
إذا صار الموضوع هذا
بيصير فيه ضغط على العملة، فلازم أحد يتحمل التكلفة هذه
لو سويناها ناس بتستفيد أكثر عن غيرها
مين المستفيد، ومين الخسران؟
المستفيد أقوى اقتصادات من المنطقة الإمارات والسعودية بيستفدون
بينما اللي بيكونوا شوي متضررين
بتكون عمان تقدر تقول والبحرين أكثر من غيرهم
بعدين ثاني شيء لو كان في فعلًا أن يعني...
شوف هي من ناحية فوائد في، ما أقول لك: ما في
بتسهل عملية التنقل من دولة لأخرى
بتسهل عملية التحويلات من دولة لأخرى
بتسهل استثمارات من دولة لأخرى، هذه كلها راح تستوي
لكن هل تسوى أن الواحد يتخلى عن السيادة اللي عنده على عملته عشانها؟
أنا أشوف أنه حاليًا في الوقت الحالي، لا
ومثال اليورو ما كان واجد ناجح إلى اليوم يضطرون يدافعون عنه باستمرار
مو ناجح يعتبر؟
ناجح للبعض ومش...، يتم أنت تسأل مني؟
تسأل ألمانيا، بتقول لك ناجح جدًّا
وتسأل الدول الأخرى تقول لك مش ناجح
الحين بتسألني، ليش مثلًا الدول قاعدة تدخل؟
كرواتيا قبل سنتين دخلت، وبلغاريا قبل دخلت، دخلوا لسبب واحد
يسهل عليهم عملية دخول السوَّاح
ويسهل عليهم عملية الاستثمارات الداخلية
يسهل عليهم استقطاب الناس
وتحويل مواطنيين يروحون يشتغلون من أماكن أخرى، ويحولوهم بيزات لهم
بس هذا لا يعني بالضرورة أنك تكون ضمن الاتحاد الأوربي
أنك تكون في اليورو
بالعكس أنك ممكن تكون في اتحاد اليورو لكن ما تلتزم بالعملة
لكن إذا بالعملة أنت لازم تكون في اليورو
ما يصير عندك العملة بدون ما تكون في الاتحاد
فممكن تكون أنت في الاتحاد لكنك ما...
بالضط
فتقدر تدخل سُوَّاح
تقدر تدخل سواحل لكن العملة تكون مختلفة
عملية أن الناس يستثمرون عندك في بلدك يخاطرون بعملية التحويلات هذه
يصير في عليهم خطر، فهذا يصير أسهل لك أنت
هل هو يشوفونه فعلًا منه فائدة أكثر؟
على ما يبدو كذلك
بالنسبة لهم يشوفون أن الإيجابيات أكثر عن الأشياء السلبية الممكن تجيهم
هل هذا الشيء راح يصير وللا لا؟ الوقت راح يبين لكن هذه فكرتهم كانت
لأنه لما تتكلم عن الخليج فاليوم في تجارة بينية عالية
أتوقع 12% تقريبًا التجارة البينية الخليجية
أن المواطنين الخليجيين يقدرون يشتغلون في أي دولة خليجية
كمواطنين تقريبًا
تقريبًا، في شروط شوي بس تقريبًا صح، في تفضيل
بس أنه بسهولة ترى هذه إقامة بدون كفيل، بدون شيء
فكثير من الأمور الموجودة في الاتحاد الأوربي مسبقًا مطبقة عنا إلى حد ما
التنقل اللي بالهوية
التنقل بالهوية
حتى الربط تقريبًا نفسه مثلًا 3.05 ريال للدولار، احنا 3.67 درهم
البحرين والكويت شوي مختلفين
الكويت عندها سلة عملات شوي تصير فيها عملية تتحرك شوي
بس برضو ثابت إلى حد ما
فأقول لك الأشياء اللي تحصلها من الاتحاد الأوربي فعليًّا كثير منها موجودة
فلو كان في فعلًا فائدة عظيمة ممكن نحصلها
كانوا دول الخليج
وبالذات وزارء الاقتصاد لدول الخليج كانوا نصحوا فيها من زمان
لكن أشوف أنه خلاص شيء مش ضرورة في الوقت الحالي
بالنسبة للإصلاحات
دائمًا الناس تنزعج من إصلاحات
أو من التوصيات اللي يطلعها صندوق النقد الدولي
ويطلعها على كل حال مثلًا آخر شيء للسعودية
كان يقترح أنه تبقى 15%
صح
ضريبة القيمة المضافة
أنه يعجلون برفع الدعم عن بقية الأشياء مثل الكهرباء وغيرها
كل نصائحهم بالنسبة للناس مستفزة ومزعجة
فما بالك في الكويت، وما بالك...
وحتى أتذكر الأردن دائمًا نصائح صندوق النقد الدولي مربكة ومزعجة
هل هم صح، بس هذا الشيء اللي يزعجنا المفترض نسويه؟
ولا هم ما يفهمون، وبس احنا جاسين نسمع لهم؟
مش موضوع أنهم ما يفهمون
شوف صندوق النقد واجبه...
أنت ما تأخذ منه فلوس
تأخذ منه فلوس، هو الملاذ الأخير يُعتبره
إذا أنت على وشك الإفلاس، وخلاص ما تقدر
يجي يقول لك خذ مني فلوس
لكن طبق شروطي واحد واثنين وثلاثة أربعة
هو عنده كتاب واحد ما يتغير، عنده شروط يمشي فيها
يقول لك: تبي تأخذ فلوس مني ترفع الدعم
وتخفض من العملة، ولو رابط العملة فك الربط
وتقوم بالإصلاحات هذه، تبيع أصول الدولة
يعني يعطيك كذا مقترح
يقول لك: طبق واحد من هؤلاء على التاريخ الفلاني
عشان أنا... كبداية يقول لك: أنا راح أعطيك مليار
نبدأ بعطيك 200 أو 150 مليون
بعدما تنفذ الشروط اللي أعطيتك إياها، وأنا أتأكد، أعطيك الباقي
احنا كدول خليج
احنا بحياتنا ما اقترضنا من صندوق النقد، أيش نحتاج منه؟
صندوق النقد شوف يجيك، ويعطيك نصائحه
هل هو على أساس أنه صندوق شر ما شر؟ لا الكلام هذا
شوف الناس يستفزها أي عملية إصلاح مزعجة بالنسبة لهم
لأن إصلاح شو يعني؟ يعني الحكومة تعطيك أقل، وتخلي في جيبها أكثر
على أساس أنها.... وتأخذ المبالغ هذه اللي تأخذها منك
تروح تحاول فيها أنها تصنع مثلما تقول نظام بيئي
على أساس أنت وغيرك تقدرون تحصلون وظائف
وتكملون، وتترزقون الأمور هذه
لأننا احنا معتمدين على النفط النصايح هذه بتستمر
بتستمر إلى أجل مسمى
وعلى فكرة كل منتدى اقتصادي تشوف وزيرة صندوق النقد البلغارية
نسيت اسمها أظن «كريستينا» ما أتذكر
بتشوفها موجودة، وتقعد مع الحكام، وأصحاب القرار
وتقول لهم يا جماعة ترا ننصحكم واحد واثنين وثلاثة وأربعة
بس في نهاية دولنا وجماعتنا يعرفون أيش الأنسب، وأيش الأصلح لنا
هل صندوق النقد ما يفهم؟ لا مش أنه ما يفهم، هو يقدم لك حلول
تبغى تأخذها ما تبغى تأخذها كيفك أنت حر
لكن هو معني بعملية الإصلاح
وعلى فكرة في كثير من الأحيان احنا نتعامل معهم
احنا نقدر نرفضهم ما بيننا أي شيء رسمي
نقدر نرفضهم، ونقول له لا تجي لا..
خصوصًا أننا ما نأخذ منهم
أقول أعطني رأيك، أعجبني أخذت فيه، ما عجبني ما أخذت فيه
لكن هل هو أثر على عملية تطبيق الضرائب؟
جائز جدًّا
لكن في النهاية عملية الضرائب ترى أنت جالس تدفعها من جيبك صح
لكنها هي قاعدة تروح للحكومة
وأنت قاعد تأخذ منها فوائد، ومسبقًا أنت ماخذ منها أشياء أكثر بكثير
سواءً من ناحية تعليم أو صحة أو الدعم العقاري
هذا كله أنت قاعد تحصلها من سنين
بعدين موضوع ضريبة القيمة المضافة يمكن شوي يختلف من عندنا وعندكم
عندنا في الإمارات يكون ملائم أكثر
لأننا احنا 10% من الشعب 10% أو 11% فقط
فالـ 90% القاعدين يدفعون مش مواطنين أصلًا
أنتم عندكم 66% تقريبًا أو 70% من الشعب
فيمكن شوي بالنسبة لكم الوضوع يكون حساس أكثر
لكن هل صندوق النقد له نية سيئة أو...؟
أنا مش مقتنع بالكلام هذا، ولا أجد فيه أي شيء من الصحة
والناس بشكل عام ما يعجبها أي شيء ممكن يمس جيبها فطبيعي
بس أنا ما يعجبني أي شيء
زي اللي يقول لك: أنك تجيب مستشار يقول لك كم الساعة
بس أنه ما هو عايش هنا أصلًا
فهو لما يقدم هذه الإصلاحات هو لن يتضرر
هو ما أحد يأخذ من جيبه ريال، وهو ما راح...
هو بس يقولها ويمشي
هذا اللي يزعجني أن هذه الإصلاحات تيجي من ناس ما يقدر يفهم
مو بالضرورة أن يكون نيتة سيئة
ما أبغى أتكلم عن النوايا، لكن أقصد أنها بعيدة عن حقيقة ماذا يقول
هل فعلًا هو بعيد؟ لأنه في النهاية هو دارس اقتصادك
وعنده ناس موجودين هنا
يشوفون أيش اللي قاعد يستوي، ويحسبون ويأخذون
والحكومة تساعدهم بالأرقام
كثير من أرقام الدخل اللي الحكومات بالعادة ما تشاركها
تشاركها مع صندوق النقد، مش مجبورة هي
تأخذها عشان تأخذ منها نصايح
شو رأيكم في هذا وهذا؟ لأن في النهاية النصيحة ما راح تضرك
إذا أنت ما بتنفذها ما راح تضرك في شيء
لكن بشكل عام هذه جاءت..
مثلما تقول، ما أعرف لو كانت قبل عشرين أو ثلاثين سنة
ولكنها تجي الحين لأن حاجتنا للتغيير جالسة تزيد
ليش كلنا عنا رؤية؟ ليش احنا عنا رؤية دبي 2033
عندكم رؤية 2030
وأنتم على فكرة أتوقع قبل تخلص الرؤية
بتشوفون رؤية جديدة عقبها على طول
بالذات بعد اللي نشوفها مع الأمير مستحيل يترك، وينام بعد 2030
ويقول لك خلاص، وجزاكم الله خير، ما قصرتوا، لا حبيبي شغالين
لا هو قال أصلًا الظاهر في 2028 بيعلن عن رؤية 2040
بالضبط، رؤية 2040
فما بيسوي هذه الأمور يا أخوي لو ما تحتاج إصلاح
الإصلاح موجود، أنت تبغى تأخد على كلامه أو ما تبي تأخد موضوع آخر
لكن جالس يعطيك من الدراسات، مو جالس يعطيك من رأيه
مش واحد قاعد، وأنه يحاول يستفزك ولا شيء من الأمور هذه
لكن الشعب ما يحب الإصلاحات
أنا أعطيك مثال هذا يمكن عشان شوية شعوبنا...، ما أبغى أقول
لكن الوعي الاقتصادي شوية ضعيف، نحتاج ننمي منه أكثر
أنت لو تقول اليوم للشعب تبون سنين التقاعد
تنزل للرجال لخمسة عشر سنة والحريم عشر سنوات؟
أنا أبصم لك الأغلبية راح يقول لك إيه
راح يقول لك: أنا ما أبغى أشتغل
أيش المشكلة في الموضوع هذا؟
أقول لك إياه بعدما أخلص النقطة هذه
طيب
حلو
لكن بس أقول لك عن موضوع الوعي الاقتصادي
قبل عشر سنوات في سويسرا
سألوا الشعب احنا بنرفع اللي هو الحد الأدنى أجرًا
أكثر اللي يشتغلون في سويسرا ترى سويسريين
نرفع حد الأدنى أجرًا إلى خمسة وعشرين دولار
اللي بيستفيد منه ناس ترى منكم وفيكم أهلكم، هل توافقون؟
70% قال لك: لا
ليش؟
قال لك: لو أنت رفعت عليهم الشركات بتسكر
لأنه أنا أقدر أفتح شركة على راتب خمسة عشر وعشرة دولار في الساعة
واللي هو كان يعتبر عالي في هذيك الأيام
خمسة وعشرين ما أقدر أفتح، الشركات راح تسكر
الناس راح تفقد وظائفها
يقول لك أنا أقدر أتحمل واحد بالراتب هذا، ما أقدر أتحمل اثنين
في خمسة وعشرين - خمسة وعشرين
ويقولون أنه بيرفع الأسعار علينا
لأنه اللي بيخليها في النهاية يضطر يرفع الأسعار
يقول لك أنهما أبغى مشكور ما قصرت
خلي الحد الأدنى نازل
واللي هذا خليه يجتهد، ويطلع فوق، ويستلم مبالغ أكثر
هذا يوم يكون عندك شوية وعي بالمترتبات الاقتصادية على القرار
اللي أنت جالس تتخذه
عرفت كيف؟
الحين تبغى تحول على نقطة التقاعد
لا بس ترى أنت تقصد أن كل الناس...، برجع للتقاعد
مش كل الناس لكن في عنا كمية لا بأس فيها من الوعي الضعيف
عنا بالنسبة لموضوع الاقتصاد
يعني أنت مثلما أقول لك: أرجع لك على النقطة
لو تقول للناس، هل ودك الحكومة تمشي لك مع ثلاث أو أربع معاشات؟
كل أحد بيقول لك: نعم
لو تسأل واحد اقتصادي راح يقول لك: لا، مستحيل
حتى لو بيمس جيبه، أغلب الظن بيقول لك: لا
راح يقول لك: هذا بيرهق، وبيحسبها
راح يقول لك هذا أيش كثر راح يرهق الميزانية؟
راح يقول لك: في النهاية أنت عندك لازم تشوف وجهه نظر الشعب كامل
ما تشوف نفسك بس
وهذا اللي يمكن الأصحاب والأقارب يشوفونها مرات
لما تقول: رفعوا الضريبة، يا أخي ليش رفعوا؟
هو يشوف أشياء أنت ما تشوفها
عرفت كيف؟
وهو بعدين مسؤول على الشعب كامل مش على واحد ولا اثنين
أنا وأنت علينا من أنفسنا
هو مو مسؤول حتى عن اليوم
هو مسؤول عن بعد عشرين وثلاثين سنة
على الأجيال القادمة
الأجيال القادمة لازم نشتغل عشانهم اليوم، ويبني لهم اقتصاد مستدام
يقدر يحتويهم كلهم على السنين القادمة
ولا على كذا أصلًا ما يحتاج نسوي كل هذا، والنفط راح يكفينا كم سنة قدام
بالضبط، وكان الله غفور رحيم
طيب، أيش مشكلتك مع التقاعد؟
شوف صناديق التقاعد هذه قصتها قصة
هات
في عندنا نظامين للتقاعد في العالم
حلو
«خطة المنافع المحددة» ما أعرف بالعربي فسامحني
«خطة المنافع المحددة» و«خطة المساهمة المحددة»
«خطة المنافع المحددة» أيش يقول لك؟
أنت يا عبد الرحمن بأخذ منك، أنتم 9% أعتقد استقطاعكم، ما أعرف كم
9-10%
أتوقع 12%
%12
بأخذ منك 12% واشتغل معي عدد سنين نظامية
روح تقاعد وما يخصك، ومعاشك بيمشي لك إلى أن يأخذ الله أمانته
هذه «خطة المنافع المحددة»
هذا بالمزايا
إي
هذا اللي مُطبق في الخليج
وفي عدد من دول العالم بس قاعد يخف اعتماده على كثير من الدول
اللي هو يقول لك أنا بأخذ استقطاع شهري
عطني الفايدة اللي تجي منك أنت
الاستقطاع هذا، وأنا أضمن لك راتب إلى أجل مسمى
ممتاز، راتبك إذا تقاعت بكمله لك
بكمله لك
ممتاز هذا
وأنا كحكومة وصندوق تقاعد أنا علي مخاطرة الاستثمار
ومخاطرة كل شيء علي أنا
أنت بس أعطيني 12% وروح نام، وما عليك من الأمور هذه
هذا ممتاز، وأنا فلوسك بأخذها راح أستثمرها
راح أستثمرها، وبضمن لك راتب تقاعدي
ممتاز
النظام الآخر «خطة المساهمة المحددة»
يقول لك: أعطيني 12% وتفضل هذه سبعة خطط استثمارية
اختار وحدة فيهم
من أقل خطورة إلى أقصى خطورة، أيش يصير فيها؟ مع نفسك
إذا قدرت تسوي فلوس فيهم، مبروك عليك
ما قدرت تسوي فلوس، الله يكون في عونك
وهذا اللي صار في الناس في 2008 على فكرة
اللي تدمروا كانوا حاطين صناديق التقاعد مالتهم
كانت حاطة كثير من فلوسها في السندات المدعومة بالرهن العقاري
اللي هي انهارت أسعارها، وخسروا كل مدخراتهم
لأنه خلاص الشركة...
الرهن العقاري
الرهن العقاري كان التقييم ماله «تريبل إيه» وكانت ماشية أموره
حطوا فيه، وخسروا كل اللي يملكونه
العالم سابقًا كله كان «خطة منافع محددة»
اللي هو أعطينا، وخلاص ما يخصك
الحين العالم يتحول إلى الثانية
يقول ليش أنا أخذ مخاطرة إعادة الاستثمار ومخاطرة أن...
يقول ليش أعور راسي؟ خلاص عليك أنت
الحين عندنا في دول الخليج، اللهم لك الحمد
عندنا نظام «خطة المنافع المحددة»
مشكلة «خطة المنافع المحددة» أنه كان مستدام في يوم من الأيام
عددنا كان بسيط، وعلى الدخل...
ودخل البترول عالي، وماشية الأمور
وكان فيه سياسات تسمح لك تشتغل سنين طويلة
الحين وصلنا لمرحلة الوضع...
الوضع شوف هو سيء عالميًّا
لكن احنا جزء من هذا العالم، أيش اللي قاعد يصير؟
المرأة السعودية أو الإماراتية في السبعينيات والثمانينيات
كانوا ينجبون ستة ونص طفل لكل امرأة، ستة ونص أو سبعة تقريبًا
بعد التسعينيات قل لأربعة ونص
واحنا ترى كنا على نفس الموجة
والحين صار الإنجاب حوالي...، بعدها فوق معدل الاستبدال
معدل الاستبدال اللي هو عشان الجيل يستبدل الجيل اللي بعده
لازم لكل امرأة 2.1
2 لاستبدال الأبوين و0.1 للنمو
للناس اللي، بعيد الشر، تموت، وما تجيب عيال
الناس اللي ما تقدر تجيب عيال، والأمور هذه
فعندك الاستبدال 2.1
واحنا حاليًا حوالي ما بين...
احنا وأنتم تقريبًا وباقي الخليج كلنا على نفس الشيء تقريبًا 2.73
حوالي هذه الحدود، لكن قاعد ينزل
الرسم البياني نزل كذا
فعندك عدد أقل داخل على سوق العمل، وعندك استثمارات
المشكلة أنه ما في إفصاحات عندنا
ما نعرف فعليًّا، كيف جالسة تؤدي؟
لكن التوقعات لو بتأخذت جميع أنحاء العالم
الاستثمارات مش قاعدة تؤدي ذاك الأداء
أنا سأصدم لو استثمارات صناديق التقارير في دول الخليج
كانت فعلًا تجيب نتائج عظيمة جدًّا
فالعدد قل، جالس يدخل سوق العمل سنة عن سنة
وعندك استثمارات مو قاعدة تجيب العوائد المطلوبة منها
كم العوائد المنطقية اللي تخلي الصندوق قادر على الاستدامة؟
يعتمد على الحجم اللي أنت عندك إياه حجم الداخل وحجم الطالع
يعتمد على السياسات كلها
لكن الحجم المنطقي المفروض يكون حوالي...
مش المنطقي، الحجم اللي أنت بتحتاجه يمكن حوالي 9-10%
إذا مش أكثر
لأن هذا جالس يعطيك كتقدير تقريبي، مش موضوع... مش رقم ثابت
أنت %9-10 بتحتاج
كم اللي قاعدين يسوون؟ هم قاعدين يفصحون
فأنت عندك أعداد أقل داخلة لسوق العمل، وعندك عوائد مش بالمستوى
أيش مشكلة الإنجاب العدد القليل اللي يدخل سوق العمل
أيش مشكلته؟
أنت ما قاعد تجيب عيال
ما قاعد يجيب عيال، وما في ناس قاعد يطلعون يشتغلون ويساهمون
لأن نظام «خطة منافع محددة» كيف يمشي؟
اللي أنت حطيته بروحك طول عمرك، ما راح يكفيك ترى
عشان النظام هذا يستمر لازم غيرك يدخل، ويحط
وأنت تأخذ المساهمة ماله
اللي نساهم فيه أنا وأنت ترى يستفيدون من المتقاعدين حاليًا
جالس يروح لهم
وعلى أمل أن عيالنا بكرة راح يدخلون يساهمون، ويعطونا احنا
أنت عندك عدد أقل قاعد يدخل
استثمارات مش قاعدة توصل للمستوى المطلوب
لو بنمشي على المستوى العالمي
وآخر شيء اللي عندك إياه هو أننا احنا قاعد نعيش فترات طويلة
يعني العمر المتوقع أيام السبعينيات والثمانينيات كان حدود الستين
زيد أو نقص شوي، حدود الستين
الحين، اللهم لك الحمد وصل ثمانية وسبعين أو تسعة وسبعين
زيد على هذا أن حتى بعد عمر طويل بعد وفاتك
الراتب ما يوقف، يكمل لعيالك إلى أن يكملوا الثمانية عشر
في كثير من الأحيان
فعليًّا العبء اللي تشكله على هيئة التقاعد يستمر خمسين سنة تقريبًا
بينما كم اشتغل؟ بالكثير ثلاثين
هذا لو أنت ما قصرت معانا، وجزاك الله خير، اشتغلت ثلاثين
الناس تتقاعد على الخمسة عشر أو عشرين
النساء في بعضهم يوصلون للشروط
أنه يتقاعدوا على الخمسة عشر، وبعضهم على العشرين سنة
ويأخذون راتبهم إلى أن موتوا؟
تروح أنت تشتغل على عشرين، وقاعد تساهم بمبلغ بسيط
الراتب اللي ساهمت فيه، مسبقًا ما جاب عائد
وتبغى تعيش، والراتب قاعد يمشي لعائلتك ستين أو خمسين سنة قدام
مين راح يتحمل التكلفة؟
بس نقدر نقول أنه مثلًا برضو أنه هيئات التقاعد أو مؤسسات التقاعد
أو صناديق التقاعد
أنها ما هي تجارية بالضرورة، فحتى لو خسرت هذا دور الحكومة
لكن أنت تتكلم بمبالغ ضخمة عشرات المليارات، مش مبلغ بسيط
عشرات المليارات تتكلم
وأنا أقول لك عشرات المليارات، وأنا أكون شوي محافظ
لو فعليًّا الخسارة بالحجم اللي الناس... ممكن تكون عشرات المليارات
ما في مشكلة هذا جزء من من الفلوس اللي تعطيها الحكومة للناس
حكوماتنا الخليجية سنويًّا قاعدة تسد العجز هذا
عجز المبالغ اللي طلعت للمتقاعدين
لكن المشكلة أن السياسة المسواية أساسًا الموجودة
ترى حتى موجود ضمان اجتماعي موجود في أمريكا، فقصدي...
بوصلك لأمريكا بقول لك مال الأمريكيين
الحكومة تعطي فلوس
أمريكا عندك الـ«فور ون كيه» و«الروث آر آي إيه» بوصلك إياهم
بنوصلهم
بس أنا قصدي فكرة أن الحكومة ما هي تستثمر، ما هو استثماري بحت
أنا لما أخلي الصندوق يشغل الفلوس ويستثمر
هو يقلل الخسائر لأنه خسران خسران
مش المفروض أن يقلل الخسائر
المفروض لو أنت تمشي بالنظام «المنفعة المحددة» خلاص أنت ما يخصك
لو أنت تمشي بالنظام «مساهمة المنفعة» أنت ما يخصك
بس تدري أنه لو خسر بتصير مشكلة
من هو؟ عفوًا
لو خسر
مين؟
نفرض أن المواطن صار عمره ستين ما يقدر يشتغل
ولا معه فلوس، لا يمكن أني أقبل
ليش تشوف لما تروح أمريكا وأوربا
ليش تشوف كاشير عمره سبعين أو خمسة وسبعين؟
هذا النظام ترى، هذا اللي قاعد يمشي
أنا ما أقول لك أن هذا صح أقول لك الواقع اللي قاعد يصير
ما قاعد أقول لك أن النظام اللي احنا نسويه سيء
أنا جالس أقول لك أنه غير مستدام، أنت عندك ناس ما يجيبون عيال
العوائد مو قاعدة توصل إلى المستوى المطلوب
وعندك ناس قاعدة تعمر لفترة أطول، ورواتبها تمشي
الخليط الغير صحي هذا يبهدل صناديق التقاعد
بشكل عام، يسبب عليها عبء ثقيل جدًّا، والحكومات قاعدة تغطي
وأتوقع بتستمر تغطي، لكن أقول لك الوضع غير مستدام
وراح تصير فيه إصلاحات في النظام...
مشكلة النظام أيش الحين؟
أنه يكافئ الشخص اللي يتقاعد من وقت
يتقاعد بالشكل هذا
لأنه كلما تقاعدت بسن أقل، المشكلة شو؟ أنت تتحول من أصل إلى عبئ
يعني أنت تتحول من أنك واحد قاعد تساهم بالنظام إلى واحد تشفط من النظام
لو نجيبها بمستوى الكرة، مهاجم يتحول مهاجم ضدك يسجل عليك أهداف
فمش بس أنه طلع من النظام أنه ما قام يساهم
لا، قام يأخذ من الطرف الآخر
فبالتالي الناس اللي قاعد تشتغل سنين أقل
تتقاعد بسرعة، وتتحول لعبء على النظام
والناس اللي عندها الرواتب أعلى، الحد مالها عالي جدًّا
قاعدة تأخذ مال يعني استقطاعات كثيرة، ويدخل حقها
فهذا النوع من خلال السياسات، الحين فيه توجه لإصلاحه
احنا في الإمارات طلع الحين توه قرار قبل أسبوعين أو ثلاثة تقريبًا
أي حد مش مسجل في نظام التقاعد في تاريخ 13، أكتوبر
13 أكتوبر كان تاريخ القطع، 13 أكتوبر أيش يستوي؟
احنا حاليًا الاستقطاعات عندنا 5%
أنا وغيري كلنا 5% اللي يصير بعدين أنه أيش؟
رح يأخدوا منك 11% وجهة عملك بتساهم بـ 15%
ويصير إجمالي المساهمات 26% من أصل 20% حاليًا
راتب التقاعد بتأخذ بـ 26% بينما حاليًا تأخذ 20%
هذا جزء من الإصلاحات، وبالعكس قرار جيد
لكن في أحد لازم يتحمل التكلفة، والتكلفة بيتحملها الجيل الجديد
بس أحس عادي لأني أتوقع ترى هذا احنا أقل شوي
احنا كم؟ أتوقع 22%
11% أو 12% على الشركة، و10% على الموظف
10% على الموظف و12% على الشركة
12% على...
لكن في النهاية أيش اللي قاعد يحصل حاليًا؟
يحصل أن الناس قاعدة تتقاعد مبكر، وتضغط على الصندوق
ليش ما يرفعون سعر التقاعد؟
هذا أصلًا راح يستوي، احنا عندنا صار
كم صار؟
أعتقد الحين صار ستين، كان قبل خمسة وخمسين
أو أنه صار خمسة وستين، ما أذكر الرقم بالضبط، لكن تم رفعه قبل فترة
وهذا أحد الحلول اللي لازم يستوي، ترفع سن التقاعد، وترفعك الحد الأدنى
بدل ما تداوم خمسة عشر سنة، تداوم عشرين سنة أقل شيء
مع أن حتى هذا قليل، لكن يساهم
وأنا في النهاية أقول لك على قناعة كاملة
أن حكوماتنا وقياداتنا ما راح تسمح أن الناس تعيش بدون رواتب
لكن أقارن لك بين الوضع عندنا وبين أمريكا
في أمريكا النظام استوى «منفعة مساهمة» عندك «401 كيه»
اللي هو أيش؟
تروح تشتغل في تسلا، يقول لك كم تبغى تحط «401 كيه» مالك؟
كحد أعلى بتحط مثلًا...
عفوًا تقدر تحط مبلغ وقدره مثلًا 2500 دولار شهريًّا
حسب سياسة الشركة بعضهم يقول لك راح نعادل لك كم حطيت
ما عليك أنت
أو بعضهم يقول لك أنا بعادل لك إلى حد معين
المبالغ هذه اللي تنحط وين تروح؟
تروح لصندوق الاستثمار اللي أنت وقعت معه
لا يوجد منافع محددة، وقفوه
أغلب الشركات وقفتها، بالذات بعدما صار مع «جي أي»
«جي أي» من كثر الثقل اللي صار عليها على صندوق التقاعد
في نكتة طلعت عليها تقول لك «جي أي» صندوق تقاعد
مع شوية أعمال تجارية على الطرف
من كثر ما صار مثقل بالديون هذه، والناس قاعدة تعيش فترة طويلة
فمن عشرة أو إثنا عشر سنة وقفوه
أنه خلاص حولوا كل أحد لـ«منفعة مساهمة»
لكن عملية التخلص من المتقاعدين هذه
راح تأخد سنين طويلة، بعدها باقي لهم واجد
فأقول لك النظام هذا مستدام
في حالة أن احنا كل عائلة قاعدة تجيب خمسة أو ستة عيال
الخمسة عيال قاعد تخلق لهم وظائف
كل خريج يحصل وظيفة مباشرة، وعوائد استثمارية ممتازة
هنا يصير النظام مستدام، لكن ولا وحده من هذه قاعد يصير
فبالتالي الحكومات الخليجية تضطر أنها تضخ مبالغ سنوية
كم؟ ما أحد يعرف، لازم تسألهم هم
تضخ مبالغ عشان تغطي العجز
فهذا بالنسبة لصندوق التقاعد، كل الناس من هذه السالفة
تزعل ولا ما تزعل، هذا هو الواقع، والناس لازم تعرف
في النهاية كلما تشتغل أقل، أنت قاعد تصير عبء على النظام
تشتغل أقل وتتقاعد
طبعًا في النهاية كل واحد والحوافز اللي عنده أيش
النظام بعد مسوى بطريقة أنك لو اشتغلت في الحد الأدنى
اللي هو أقل مدة
بتأخذ 50 أو 60% من راتبك فقط
كلما تشتغل أطول كلما أنت يحق لك بنسبة أعلى من راتبك
وهذا الصح، ويشجعون الناس أن يشتغلون فترات أطول
وأتوقع أن في ناس تهكر النظام
أيش راح يسوون؟ طبعًا كذا جالس يخرب على الكل
أو يتوظف من عمره صغير ثمانية عشر من أول ما يسمح
بـ 2000 ريال بأي شيء، بس أني دخلت في السوق
ويقعد في النظام التأمينات الاجتماعية
ولأنهم يعطون الراتب، أتوقع ما عندي معلومة
أتوقع أنهم يعطون الراتب بناءً على آخر خمس سنوات
آخر خمسة، لازم أرد أراجع الشروط، بس أعتقد
فراتبك يمكن يقعد 2000 أو ثلاثة لعشر سنين
فأنت تُحسب أنك اشتغلت عشرة سنين، وأنت ما كنت تشتغل
بعدين تبدأ تشتغل ما أدري شلون
آخر خمس سنين إذا كان راتبك 30 ألف
بيعطونك على الـ30 ألف الأخير
بس وين...
ما يعطونه على الإجمالي متوسط راتبك؟
بس عشان تشتغل عشان...، لازم توصل لعمر معين
أعتقد تشتغل توصل لعمر معين بالإضافة...
هل هو عمر ولا عدد سنوات؟
أظن يكون الأعلى منهم، الأعلى أو لا عفوًا
عمر أو عدد؟ مش متأكد صراحة
بس أنت متخيل أني راح أعطيك على متوسط آخر خمس سنوات حقتك
يعني أنت خسارة هنا، وفي الأخير أنا بعطيك على أعلى شيء أنت جبته
لكن مشكلته أنك تقول مثلًا لنفرض أنك تبغى تعيش على النظام هذا
أنت خلصت عمرك ثمانية عشر
وصل عمرك خمسة وأربعين قلت بتقاعد على الراتب هذا
الراتب هذا اللي تقول لي: ثلاثين ولا خمسة وعشرين، كم بيسدك؟
أنت في نهاية تحط بالك أنت ناوي تكمل
إذا الله طول في عمرك، بتكمل إلى الثمانين
هل الثلاثين هذه بتسدك للثمانين مع التضخم اللي قاعد يستوي كل سنة؟
ما عليه، بس أنا إذا طلعت الآن راتبي هذا
أشتغل أو ما أشتغل موضوع ثاني
هذا موضوع آخر، هذا دور السياسات أنها تحد من العملية هذه
وتخلي الناس الواحد يشتغل لسنين طويلة
عشان كذا أقول لك السياسات تغيرت، وبتستمر بالتغير لصالح العملية هذه
لأن الإصلاحات في النطاق هذا ضروري
طيب الحين هذول السياسات
أحس السياسات جالسة تشتغل أنها تغير، وما أدري أيش
جالسة تخلق فرص كثيرة، لأنها أعلى من الناس
اليوم مع كل هذه التغيرات
فيه ناس تقول، وخصوصًا بعد «إكسبو» وكأس عالم في السعودية
أن الناس تقول أنه هذه كأنها طفرة جديدة، اللي هي طفرة السبعينيات
ما مدى دقَّة هذا الكلام؟
وأن لازم تستغلها، ولازم تروح تسوي حاجة جديدة لأنه إذا ما سويتها
لأن أيش اللي يجيي في بال الناس الآن؟
دائمًا يقولون اللي كان في السبعينيات كان أي أحد يشتغل الحين مليونير
اليوم، هذيك طفرة، هل هذه طفرة ثانية وللا لا؟
هل هي ممثلة أو لا؟ مش بالطريقة هذه
هي بتقدم إضافة كبيرة للاقتصاد لكن مش بالطريقة هذه
الإضافة اللي صارت في دبي
أعطيك المثال، في دبي اللي صار أن بعد الحصول على «إكسبو»
تم بناء البنية التحتية بشكل كبير من وسط دبي إلى «إكسبو»
شوارع وجسور ومحطات مترو وغيرها من الأمور هذه
صارت دعمًا للمعرض هذا
فالميزة هي أن الأمور هذه راح تستمر معك حتى بعدما يخلص المعرض
الحين عندنا شركات ضخمة قامت تنتقل لمنطقة «إكسبو»
وشغالة من هناك، ومستفيدة من المكان هذا
والحين منطقة «إكسبو» مستضيفين فيه «كوب 28»
فالمنطقة هذه صارت منطقة مثلما تقول حية على طوال السنة
وصارت عندك ناس قاعدة تروح وتيجي
في تقرير قامت به «أرنستي يونق»
اللي هي شركة تدقيق لكن عندهم استشارة بعد
قاموا بالتقرير يقول لك العاد المتوقع على اقتصاد دبي
على عشرين سنة بعد «إكسبو» 42 مليار دولار
هل في نوع من المبالغة؟ جائز
لكن بشكل عام أن يكون حتى لو أنت وصلت لنص المبلغ
اللي هو بيتعدَّا المبالغ اللي أنت صارفها أصلًا في البنية التحتية
أنت تكون أنجزت إنجاز
الحين لو رحنا لموضوع السعودية عندكم أنتم
أيش راح تسوي الأمور هذه؟
أنتم حاليًا عندكم مثلًا بالذات في الرياض
لأن الأمور هذه أغلبها الرياض بتكون أكبر المستيفدين
لكن السعودية كلها بشكل عام بتستفيد
عندكم تحتاجون مثلًا الشيء راح يساهم في عملية أول شيء المترو
راح تكون عندك نقاط يمكن إضافية أخرى
عملية الفنادق وعملية المدارس
بالذات على وقت المعرض ووقت كأس العالم
راح تكون كمية شركات بالفعل انتقلت للمنطقة
بتكون في وظائف موجودة في المنطقة
الرياض بتكون توسعت أكثر مما هي متوسعة الحين
فالأمور هذه كلها راح تلعب دور
أيش القطاعات بالضبط اللي راح تستفيد؟
هذا ما راح يبين الحين لأن كل دولة لها نظام مختلف
«إكسبو» الصين نجح بشكل كبير
لأن 70% من الزوار كانوا الصينيين نفسهم
في دبي حصلنا 24 مليون زيارة
لكن هذا كان يشمل أرقام الناس اللي دخلوا أونلاين
وتحضر جلسات وتحضر وتشوف تدخل أونلاين
لأنه كان توه التعافي من كورونا
فالعالم مش كله كان مفتوح
لهذا السبب كان الوضع شوية...
المفروض يكون أكثر بكثير، ولكن بالرغم من أن هذا نجح
وحتى في بالسعودية بينجح، لا شك عندي في الموضوع هذا
لكن عملية بناء البنية التحتية اللي راح تصير عندكم
بالنهاية هذا أنت وحظك
احنا عندنا مثلًا العقارات اللي عداها محطات القطار، طارت في السعر
وين بتبني المحطات؟ وين بتبني الفنادق؟ وين بتبني الملاعب؟
هذا بالنسبة لإكسبو، ولكن بالنسبة لكأس العالم والملاعب بالذات
ما بقول لك أن الأثر عليها ضعيف
لكن لا تصنع تجارة كاملة، وعلى هدف أنك تربح من شهر
ترى الشهر بيخلص
والحين قبل فتره طالعين بتقارير في «بلومبرق» وغيره
أن قطر قاعدة شوي تعاني من بعد...
مش موضوع تعاني
لكن الحركة فيها مش قادرين يرجعون لما قبل كأس العالم
بيرجعون طبعًا بيأخذ لها وقت شوية
لكن بسبب الحجم والزخم اللي صار في كأس العالم
كمية الصرف، وقطر صرفت حوالي 200 مليار في كأس العالم
سبعة منها على الملاعب سبعة أو ثمانية أو تسعة عفوًا
بس أقل من عشرة أكيد على الملاعب
الباقي كله كان بنية تحتية
البنية التحتية هل الناس تستخدمها كلها؟ لا
لكن مستقبلًا لو خلقوا سياسات مناسبة
أن الناس تروح وتقعد في قطر تستثمر فيها، لا شك أنها بتنجح
صح بتنجح فأقول لك هذه هي اللي...
بالذات عندكم أنتم بموضوع البنية التحتية
هو اللي أكثر شيء بيلعب دور خاصةً مع زحمة الرياض
وأتوقع كلكم شايفينها، وأنا كلما أجي هنا نفس الموضوع
لا تكلمني في زحمة الرياض عشان لا أبكي
وخصوص أنه باقي ما اكتمل العدد
يقول لك يبغى لهم 7 مليون زيادة
7 مليون زيادة يببيجي عندك
والشوارع عندكم أنا متوقع مسوية كأنها منهاتن
كل شارع عندك إشارة، وكمل هنا، وكمل هناك يعني عملية متعبة
بدون وسائل النقل العام، عملية صعبة
وسائل النقل العام بتحل لكم مشاكل ضخمة
احنا لو تروح الحين تشوف دبي مترو
فل أوقات الصباح وأوقات المساء فل
يعني كمية الناس اللي تستخدمها بشكل يومي
للذهاب والعودة من العمل مهولة
وهذا الشيء طلع قرار «الشيخ محمد بن راشد»
الخط الأزرق
تمديد خطوط المترو إلى مناطق أخرى في دبي
رغم أنه خط واحد وما يخدم كل المدينة
يعني واضح أنه يخدم نوع معين من المدينة
يخدم جزء معين من المدينة، صح
ومع ذلك فل
مع ذلك فل
إن شاء الله، يعجل بقطار الرياض
والله أتمنى
أنا كل يوم جاي أشوف القطار يمشي لحاله
متى نركب جواه؟ هذا السؤال، يبقى حائرًا
الله يعين
طيب، الله يعطيك العافية
والله تشرفنا ومشكورين على الاستضافة الطيبة
شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لعمر الشنقيطي: في إعداد الحلقة
وخلف الكاميرات: وهَّاب موسى
وفي التسجيل الصوتي: عبدالعزيز المزي
والهندسة الصوتية: حمد الحسن
وفي التحرير: محمد نور شمَّت
والتلوين: عبدالمجيد العطاس
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي: نورة السبيعي
وفي إدارة الإنتاج: أصيل بافرط
ومنتج البرنامج: أيمن الحمادي
وإدارة التحرير: أسيل با عبد الله
هذا فنجان، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض، الأسبوع المقبل ألقاكم
على فك الارتباط بالدولار
قرأت لك تغريدة
ذكرت عرضًا أن فك الارتباط راح يحدث في المستقبل بس ليه بيصير؟
هل احنا بعدنا قاعدين نصور وللا لا؟
إي، نصور
موضوع فك الارتباط بالذات
حاليًا أغلب 70% من دخلك يأتي من النفط
ونفط الدخل هذا أيش قاعد تسوي فيه؟
جزء تصرفه على الدولة، وجزء تضعه في صندوق الثروة السيادية
اللي هي صناديق مثل «البي آي إف» وغيرها
تستثمر برة على البلاد
وجزء قاعد تحطه عندك في صندوق الثروة السيادية
الاحتياطات الخارجية
احتياطات الخارجية
فبالنسبة لك تحتاج الدولارات هذه عشان تصرف على اقتصادك
لأن أغلب الاشياء اللي تستوردها من برة تحتاج عليها دولار
احنا حاليا لسنا دول صناعية
مو قاعدين نصنع شيء أنت مو قاعد تصدر برة
احنا نبي ناس تيجي سياحة
على فكرة لدبي أفضل شيء راح يكون هو فك الربط لدبي
ليه؟
السياحة في دبي تعتبر غالية بسبب الدولار
لو تفك الدولار عن دبي فقط، ولو أن يعتبر هذا غير منطقي وغير واقعي
لكن لو تفك الربط دبي أكثر واحدة بتستفيد
لأن السياحة عنده بتكون أرخص بكثير
الناس بتجي من كل مكان
فطالما أنت دولة معتمدة على مصدر دخل واحد
بتضطر تخلي الربط هذا
لأنك مستفيد منه، لأنه شوف الربط هذا يعتمد على الثقة
أكثر من أي شيء آخر، كيف؟
اليوم ساما تتابع بشكل مستمر
حجم الدولار وحجم...
إذا صار فيه أي خلل لنفرض أنا مستثمر عندي 200 مليون ريال
جايبها من هذا المكان
وجاي أبي أسوي «بيع مكشوف» دق في راسي وأريد أسوي «بيع مكشوف» عن الريال
أروح أكلم البلوك وأبيع
على ثالث أو رابع واحد أكلمه على بلوك ضخم
ساما بيصحون لك، يقولوا: تعال حبيبي من الذي جالس يبيع هذا؟
لأن أيش يستفيد؟ يتابعون السوق المستقبلي الذي يصير مستقبلًا
بعد شهر أو ثلاث شهر
يشوفوا أن قاعد يختل التوازن
من هذا ومن وين جايب مئاته؟ أنتم أعطيتوه؟
وللا هل هو قاعد يحاول يتلاعب بالعملة؟
ليش ما تواصل مع البنك المركزي مباشرة؟ ليش ما...
يشوفون هل هي فعلًا محاولة؟
فيه رقابة شديدة على الموضوع هذا
نفس الشيء للموضوع السندات
أنا عندي سندات مثلًا السعودية 2024 أبي أعمل عليها «بيع مكشوف»
أخذ من هذا، وأخذ من ذاك
أتسلف منهم لأعمل عليها «بيع مكشوف»
أني أراهن ضدها وتنزل في السوق
على ثاني أو ثالث أحد أكلمة الخبر سينتشر
ترى السوق جدًّا صغير، بالذات أسواق السندات وأسواق العملة جدًّا صغيرة
ساما تقول مين اللي ماسك الموضوع هذا
وقاعد يحاول يتلاعب بالعملية هذه؟
ما جاءت ع بالك مثلًا ،ليش ولا أحد الحين عمل «بيع مكشوف» مثلُا
على أي عملة خليجية على أساس يحاول يفك الربط مثل جورج سورس
مثلًا يقول أصغر دولة في الخليج البحرين
ليش ما حد فكر أحد يحاول فكر يستفيد من هذه العملية؟
ما تقدر تحصل دينار، ما أحد بيعطيك
لأن الدول الخليجية بالذات
هذا جزء من عملية أن ليش ما قاعدين نسوي عملة موحدة؟
لأننا مركزين بشكل كبير على عملاتنا
وين قاعدة تروح، ومن يأخذها، وأيش قاعد يسوي بها؟
ليش في بريطانيا مع بريطانيا...
بريطانيا عملتها عالمية، يمكن أن تحصل الباوند في أي مكان
لكن احنا لا، ما راح تحصل، تروح أي مكان ما را يكون عنده ريال
الريال رح يكون بالبنوك السعودية
البنوك السعودية ما راح تعطيك، منا والطريق
وإذا طلعت لك، تعرف أيش السبب؟ أيش قاعد تسوي فيها؟
فليش ما أحد قاعد يسوي مثلُا مع البحرين؟ ما يقدر يحصل
البنوك البحرينية بعد مبلغ معين يقولون لك أيش الهدف وأيش قاعد تسوي؟
وأيش اللي قاعد تحاول...؟
بعدين في النهاية الحكومة بتشتري... حتى اللي يحاول يبيعها
الحكومة تستنفد من احتياطياتها النقدية
وتروح تشتري منها مرة ثانية، لكن السؤال هو
كيف واحد بقدر يسوي «بيع مكشوف» لأي دولة أخرى؟ وكيف يقدر...؟
أن يقنع عامة الناس، أن الدولة هذه ما تقدر تدافع عن العملة
لكن احنا عندنا العملة خط أحمر
العملة والبترول خطين حمر ما أحد يلمسهم
قبل أعتقد سنة أو سنتين وزير النفط عندكم «الأمير عبدالعزيز»
كان هناك مجموعة تقرير أن سعر النفط متضخم، والطلب عليه أكثر بكثير
وراح تنزل، وراح تعمل عليه «بيع بالمكشوف»
طلع الأمير «عبدالعزيز» قال اللي يحاولون يتلاعبون بسوق النفط
أيش كانت الكلمة؟ سوف نريهم أو شيء من هذا
أن يعني لا تلعبون. لأنه يقول، احنا سندافع عنه بكل ما أوتينا، ولا تتحدونا
سعر النفط وقتها على طول ارتفع بعد التصريح
الأسواق تعتمد على الثقة، اقتصادنا كله يعتمد على الثقة أكثر من أي شيء آخر
ليش اليوم روسيا مثلًا عندها كمية ضخمة من الدراهم الإماراتية
تثق أن الإمارات بتحافظ على العملة ما بتصير مكان
لأنها هي ما تقدر تأخذ دولار
والإمارات ما تقدر تبيع دولار ممنوع
فعلى تجارتها مع الهند، قالت الهند أنها ستدفع بالربية
وروسيا رفضت، قالت ما أبي روبية
الروبية كل فترة تخفض وتنزل
والهند قالت: ما أقدر أستقبل...
فقالت حق الإمارات احنا راح نأخذ منكم...
درهم
نأخذ منهم درهم
أخذوا الدرهم، عفوًا الهند أخذت الدرهم، وأعطته لروسيا
والدرهم محفوظ في البنوك الإماراتية
مذكور في «رويترز» وغيرها
لأن الثقة عندنا عالية بالذات بالعملة
واحنا عنا الدفاع عن العملة خط أحمر
أكثر عن أي شيء آخر، وجدَّا مهم
بس أيش اللي بيخلينا ننفصل عن الدولار؟
هل بننفصل، ونصير زي الكويت مثلًا؟
عندك شيء تصدره غير البترول؟
لا
أيش تصدر غير البترول؟
ولا شيء
ليش تبي تخفض من عملتك الريال؟
بس الكويت حطوا...
سلة عملات
الكويت حطو سلة عملات
لكن سلة العملات ثمانين أو خمسة وثمانين منها دولار
وهي بس أنها سلة عملات
لها أسبابها المعينة عشان تلعب في ضمن نطاقها
لكن حتى نطاق السعر اللي حاطينه ترى جدًّا ضعيف
مش أنها 10 أو 15% لا وين
لما يكون عندك أشياء تصدرها
هل ممكن للخليج أن يصل لهذه المرحلة ولا؟
ممكن جدًّا، ليش مش ممكن؟
بس سؤالي، نرجع للموضوع اللي تكلمنا عنه في بداية الحلقة
بتصدر السيارات يعني؟
تصدر السيارات هي صعبة ما أقول لك مش ممكنة
هي صعبة لكن ممكنة
شوف على قولة فيزيائي يقول أي قانون قابل للكسر
إلا قوانين الفيزياء
كل شيء تقدر تسويه، قوانين الفيزياء الوحيدة اللي ما تقدر تكسرها
فهل ممكن؟ كل شيء ممكن
كل شي ممكن
هل لو بنصنع السيارات، إن شاء الله، ليش لا
مع وجود قيادات حالمة، وتطمح
مع وجود صانع قرار فعلًا عنده الرغبة والنية
وحوله مستشارين ناس فاهمين وزينين، ليش لا؟
وجالسين نشوف التطور هذا
شوف الإمارات والسعودية والبحرين وعمان
جالس تشوف الشيء هذا في كل مكان
فليش لا؟
بس إلى ذاك الوقت أنت ما عندك حافز أنك أنت تكسر الربط مالك مع العملة
ما قاعد تصدر شيء، تكسرها أيش بتستفيد؟
وأنت حط في بالك أنت قاعد تستورد تقريبًا كل شيء
أشياء بسيطة، شوف اللابتوب اللي تستعمله والكاميرا هذه كلها مستوردة
أيش قاعد تصنع عندك محليًّا؟ ما قاعد تصنع واجد
الشيء الوحيد...، لو عندك سياحة عالية جدًّا شوي في له مغزى
بس قبل شوي أقول لك أرجع لك لو صار في هبوط للعملة
دبي بتستفيد بشكل ضخم
لكن كمصلحة عليا لا
المصلحة العليا ما تزال أن أحافظ على الربط إلى أشعار آخر
بس سبب واحد اللي يخلينا نفكر إذا صار عندك شيء تصدره
ما له دخل مثلًا بسياسة أمريكا
لنفرض يوم من الأيام صحينا ما فيه أمريكا، لنفرض فرضًا جدلًا
هذا موضوع آخر، هنا أنت مجبور
بس أيش الشيء المرشح أو العملة المرشحة الثانية
اللي هي تكون البديلة عنها؟
ما في عملة مرشحة بديله عنها لا يورو ولا يان ولا شيء
ولا يوان؟
ولا يوان
يوان حجم تداوله بين العملات العالمية كان حتى ظني شيء بسيط
عفوًا كحجم من الاحتياطيات العالمية 2-3% شيء بسيط
اليوان ما تبغى تكون عملة عالمية أصلًا
خلها عندها هي تقدر ترفع فيها على كيفها، ما تبغى تكون...
ما لها معنى، أنا دولة مصدرة ليش أبغى العالم كله يأخذ عملتي؟
اليوان نفسها قاعدة تجمع دولار، تأخذ دولار من أمريكا، وتودعها عندها
حق أيش تحتاج لها ليش أخلي عملتي عالمية
وأخلي العالم كله يطالع عمليتي وأيش يستوي فيها
وما أقدر أخفض على كيفي؟
لأنك تكون عملة عالمية لازم يكون فيه اتزان
اتزان سياسي واتزان اقتصادي
الاتزان الاقتصادي موجود لكن أنت بحكم أن الصين دولة تصدر تقريبًا كل شيء
تبي تخفض عملتها على كثر ما يدق في رأسها
فما له معنى أن...
يساعدها على التصدير
نعم
بالضبط، يساعدها على التصدير
تعال، حياك
بعدين حط في بالك حتى لو فكّينا الربط
احنا في حياتنا من بدأت دولنا ما تحكمنا بالسياسة المالية الخاصة بنا
ما أقول لك أنه ما نقدر، لا طبعًا نقدر
وكفاءات موجودة لكن ما قد صارت
دائمًا أمريكا ترفع هذا رفعنا، وتنزل نزلنا، خلاص معاهم
الشيء اللي نطالعه أيش كثر نطبع فلوس، نطبع احنا، كل أحد يطبع
لكن ما تطبع على...، أيش الآلية اللي تتم الطباعة عليها؟
ما أحد بيقول لك
هل مقابل كل دولار تطبع؟ ما تعرف
هل مقابل كل دولار ونص تطبع؟
لأنه شوف حجم الريالات أو الدراهم اللي كانت في السوق قبل خمسين سنة
والموجودة اليوم مش نفس الشيء، تغيرت
فيه طباعة قاعدة تستوي، كم وكيف؟ ما بتعرف
لازم تسأل ويخبرونك، إذا بيخبرونك
ما بيخبروك
بس على كل حال
دولنا أثبتت من خلال سياسات اقتصادية سليمة على مدى سنين طويلة
أن الربط بالدولار شيء لا يُمس
وإذا بنفكه بنفكه متى ما كان مناسب اقتصاديًّا لنا
طالما أن أمريكا اقتصاديًّا سليمة
بس على فكرة ما يحتاج أمريكا توافق عليك عشان تربط عملتك فيها
ما تحتاج هي توافق، وما يحتاج هذا...
بس يفضل يكون لك معها تنسيق
ويفضل أن يكون لديك دخول مستمر للدولار لبلدك
عشان تقدر تحافظ عليه، ولا كيف بتحافظ؟
الحين واحدة من تحديات الأرجنتين
يقول لك أنا بسوي دولار للاقتصاد كامل
كيف بتدخل الدولار هذا كله؟
هذا تحدي ترى
هل بيقدر؟ يمكن، هو على فكرة اقتصادي ترى الرجل
هذا «خافيير بالي» اقتصادي، وأفكاره غير مألوفة
بيجرب وبتكون صراحة تجربة مثيرة للاهتمام جدًّا
جدًّا
هذا يبي يعفس
وبالنسبة للأرجنتينيين
كنت أسأل الاقتصادي من أمريكا الجنوبية أقول له
ليش الأرجنتين أخذوا هذا وليش رشحوه؟
قال: بالنسبة لهم كلهم العملية بسيطة
احنا نعاني من سنين، عملتنا في الأرض، ودولتنا مديونة
صندوق النقد كل يوم والثاني يفرض شروطه علينا
نبغى نغير تعبنا، هذا يوفر حل بديل جيد أو سيء ما نعرف، بس خلنا نجرب
لأن احنا ما نتوقع أن وضعنا بيكون أسوء مما احنا عليه حاليًا
مثل لبنان
مثل لبنان، فتجربة مثيرة للاهتمام
أيش اللي راح يصير؟ راح يبين مع الوقت